[Zene]
üdvözöllek árpád örülök hogy elfogadtad
a
meghívásomat szeretném bemutatni a
hallgatóinknak vincellér arpádó
taveekker közösségnek az alapítóját és a
tulajdonosát nagyon röviden és
visszafogottan nyilatkoztál magadról
amikor kérdeztem a hogy hogy mit mit
esetleg mi az amit érdemes rólad tudni
azt mondtad hogy 20 éve dolgozol a
vendéglátásban és közel 20 éve röviden
mesélnél erről hogy hogy milyen
tapasztalatod volt hol az elmúlt 20
évben ezzel kapcsolatban először is
köszönöm szépen a meghívást meg
köszöntök mindenkit
persze a
vendéglátással
2001-ben találkoztam először akor ilyen
14 éves voltam majdnem 15
az volt hogy kilencedik osztállyal
végeztünk és el akartam kezdeni dolgozni
vakációba merthogy kell a pénz há igen
mer kellett a pénz meg
meg egyébként is az bennem volt hogy
nyáron igen nyáron dolgozzunk és az
akkori elekes kávézóó biztos van tehát
mikorosztályun még emlékszik rá ott
kezdtem el dolgozni mint pincérl hát el
se tudom képzelni egyébként most
egy
kilencedikes gyerekre hogyha ránézek nem
tudnám elképzelni hogy nem is tudom hogy
hogy hogy jött ez nekem hogy ott
dolgozzak de akkor ismerkedtem meg amúy
a korosztályod hasonlóan dol dolgozott
vagy te ilyen szempontból ki abszolút
abszolút hát van most is egy-két srác
akivel találkozok akivel ann együtt
dolgoztunk az elekesben és egy idősök
voltunk ühüm és akkor ott kezdtem el
dolgozni az volt az első nyár mikor
dolgoztam akkor lejárt a a nyár jött a
suli megint egy évet jártam suliiban
következő évben egy másik helyen kint a
táborneretben nőttem én fel egyébként
üüm és ott volt egy elit biliardrdszalon
ez volt a neve hogy elit bar biliárd
szalon és akkor ott dolgoztam nyáron
akkor a harmadik nyáron már úgy volt
hogy végeztem a vagy tehát vége lett a
vakációnak akkor is már dolgoztam ott az
elitpárban vége lett a vakációnak és
kezdődött a suli de akkor is dolgoztam
tehát hogy lejárt a suli nem tudom kettő
háromkor é ötre mentem délután de mi az
ami motivál téged hogy ennyit feládoz
szerettem ezt a ezt a ezt az egészet azt
a légkört azt lég igen igen igen meg
magát a munkát is meg emberekkel
találkoztam rengeteg embert megismertem
rengeteg hogy mondjam
más emberekkel találkoztam meg meg ez az
egész légkör nem tudom szerettem nem
tudom megmagyarázni na hát körülbelül
akkor kezdődött 15 évesen most vagyok 36
akkor 20 éve akkor nem közel 20 éve
hanem több mint 20 éve igen több mint á
21 benne vagyok igen igen
utána mikor vége lett a sulinak akkor
felkerüttem kolzsvárra elmentem egyetem
egyetemre egyetemistának aztán az
egyetemet eg földre az egyetemre
iratkoztam be mai napig nem tudom hogy
miért
az nem az nem nem tehát a a a hány éves
volt az egyetem három éves volt
körülbelül félig jutottam el félig
jutottál el érezted hogy ez nem a tied
pontosan de fél év után éreztem hog nem
az elém aztán még egy egyet erőtettem de
egyébként három év ott laktam
kolozsváron és már az első fél év végén
volt nek van nekem egy barátom aki
dolgozott egy helyen ő építészmérnök
tanult abban az évben
államvizsgázott és akkor mondta hogy az
utolsó fél évet azt már nem dolgoznál le
mert ő is dolgozott végig és akkor
helyette mentem egy tranzit ház nevű
kávézóba az egy emlékszem igen rá
emlékszel rá igen az egy művészkávézó
volt meg egy ilyen közösségi tér
gyakorlatilag ahol jártak újságírók írók
költők mindenféle művészek nagyon jó
társaság volt nagyon jó közösség volt és
akkor ott is elkezdtem dolgozni aztán
dolgoztam egy másfél évet aztán
átkerültem egy másik helyre egy udvaregy
srác nyitott ott egy üüm egy ilyen
pubszerűséget akkor átkerültem oda tehát
azt is átszőtt akkor kolzvári éve azt
akartam mondani a kolozvári éveimet is
átszőtte a
vendéglátás és akkor utána hazajöttem ez
egy már 2010 ühüm akkor jöttem haza
akkor itt a retróra hogyha valaki
emlékszik most
523 régeb r
akkor ott ott dolgoztam egy évet akkor a
barátaimmal eldöntöttük hogy kimegyünk
ciprusra hüm ott is vendéglátozni ott
szállodaiparban ott mennyi ideig voltál
ott egy szezont az hét hónap ühüm hét
hónap tehát márciustól november elején
jöttünk haza azér így azéry brutál jó
tehát hogy azt kell tudni ciprusról hogy
ha mondjuk külföldre pénzt keresni mész
akarsz menni akkor ciprust nem szabad
választani tehát nem voltunk megfizetve
viszont egy olyan élményt kaptunk meg
annyi embert megismertünk meg tehát mai
napig vannak szlovák vagy lengyel
haverjaim hogyha kimennék most
lengyelországba sose voltam de hogyha
kimennék akkor fogadnának igen tehát
hogy fel tudnék v rá tudnék írni
valakire tehát az egy óriási élmény volt
akkor az nagyon nagy láz volt egyébként
2010-12 között udvarhelyre ugye hogy
kezdődik ez az egész három ember kimegy
akkor ott elmondják hogy ott
folyamatosan emberszűke van tehát
folyamatosan jönnek az emberek dolgozni
teehát elmondják hogy ha valakit tudsz
akkor hívjad akkor az felhívtak ők üüm
jöztek és akkor mint van egy barátom
például aki most nem rég küldött egy egy
képet egy kávéscsészével meg kapott a
tesojáté kávésész hogy ott lakik 10 éve
több mint 10 éve ott nevelik a
gyereküket meg ő teljesen kint ragadm
cipruson úgyhogy na akkor jött a ciprusi
időszak akkor hazajöttem és akkor amikor
ciprusról hazajöttem akkor lehúztam
kilenc évet itt egy egy cégnél üüm tehát
dolgoztam étteremben éjszakában pubba
ühüm kávézó részen meg mindenhol igen a
a a magadról amikor írtál akkor ezt
írtad hogy mindened a a munka nem hogy
mindened hanem nagyon fontos számodra a
munka és látszik is rajtad hogy nagyon
élvezed és amikor gondolkoztam hogy k
akiket hívok meg mi mint vendég elsőként
te jutottál eszembe hogy az elsők között
és ennek két oka van az egyik az hogy
amikor a médiaműhely megalakult akkor
körbejártam itt a városban hogy hogy
lássam hogy kik lennének azok akik
érdekeltek lennének bármilyen formában
és amikor leültünk körülbelül két perc
után láttam hogy érdekel ez a dolog
éreztem egy nyitottságot rajtad amit
amúgy
nehéz ritkán látok ezt ilyenfjta
nyitottságot de gyanítom hogy így ahogy
majd belemegyünk a történetedben azért
még
fogunk hasonló nyitottsággal találkozni
mert az hogy elmenj ciprusra az is egy
bizonyos szempontból a nyitottságodnak a
köszönhető és a másik dolog az pedig az
hogy a a wecker kv közösség ami amúgy a
médiaműhelynek a főtmogatója minden ami
kv a
médiaműhely médiaműhelynek a vekker
által lesz
szolgáltatva szóval szóval ez a
nyitottság amit
tapasztaltam párosult valami olyan
érzéssel amit szeretnék boncolgatni egy
kicsit még pedig az hogy a weckernek
volt egy identitása tehát amikor
bementem bármelyik weckkerbe éreztem
hogy itt ez ez bizonyos szempontból nem
véletlen lehet hogy nem fogalmaztad meg
szavakkal hogy konkrétan mit is akarsz
az is lehet hogy megfogalmaztad de
mindenesetre nem véletlenszerűen alakult
úgy ahogy alakult és egy identitása van
ennek a helynek látszik hogy vonzza az
embereket és ezért is akartam egy kicsit
beszélgetni veled hogy hogyan jutottál
arra a döntésre hogy visszaköltöz ide ez
az egyik
kolozsvárról majd ciprusról
és és utána pedig hogy hogyan kezdtél
neki ennek felépíteni ezt a kávézóláncot
és ezt azért is kérdezem mert még látom
hogy az elején vagy bizonyos szempontból
mondhatná valaki valaki hogy már most
befutottál de nekem az az érzésem hogyha
10 év múlva ülnék le megint találkozni
akkor lehet hogy egy olyan kávézólánc
tulajdonosa leszel ahol több városban
lehet hogy több országban lesznek majd
kávézóid attól függően hogy a hogy nem
tudom hogy van-e erre ambíciód de
abszolút benne van a potenciálba azt
amit érz abba amit érzek benned
úgyhogy egy kicsit kicsit erről hogyha
tudnál beszélni hogy hogyan indult az
ötlet hogy hogy elindítsd ezt a wecker
kávéközösséget honnan jön a név először
is miért vcker először visszamennék egy
kicsit még az időb azt kifelejtettem
hogy 2014-ben még volt egy külföldi
próbálkozásunk igen ugyanígy kint voltak
haverok barátok kihívtak oxfordba
szállodat szinten szállodamelóx
bennem már bennem mindig is az az érzés
megvolt hogy hogyha tudsz boldogulni
akkor bárhol tudsz a világon tehát nem
kell ah kimenni külföldre mi mégis
kimentünk oxfordra oxfordt milyen szé
egy pillanat itt egyből két kérdés
felmerült hogy hogy honnan jön ez az
érzés mert ha most egy akármelyik
fiatalt vagy eg tipikus fiatalt
megkérdezek én nem mondanám azt hogy ez
egy magától értetődő érzés hogy bárhol
megállom a helyem hogyha ha elindulok mi
eznek hova nyúlnak vissza hogy a kereje
ennek az érzésnek szerinted
mindjárt majd rátérünk a vállalkozásra
meg a vackkerre de tehát nyilvánvaló
hogyha valamilyen jó dolgot csinál akár
vállalkozóként akár egy cégnek az
alkalmazottjaként hogyha van egy olyan
képességed
amivel valakinek valamilyen valamivel
jobbá tudod tenni az
életét akkor akkor valószínűleg
mindenhol fogsz érvényesülni a világbaan
tehát hogyha van egy olyan készséged
képességed akár hajlamod rá hogy
valakinek hogy jobbá akarod tenni
valakinek az életét akkor mindegy hogy a
világnak melyik részén vagy igazából meg
a vállalkozás is innen indul igazából
tehát hogy így én úgy gondolom hogy egy
egy jó vállalkozás is így kell
felépüljön tehát hogyha én asztalos
vagyok és azt akarom
hogy te rendezsz tőlem egy konyhabútort
ühüm és én úgy akarom azt elkészíteni
hogy hogy te utána boldog legyél meg
szívesen kifizesd nekem meg tovább
ajánljál és
hajlandó vagyok én ezt megcsinálni és
azáltal én valami jót csináltam neked
akkor azt jelenti hogy tehát hogy ebből
kell kiinduljon igazából egy vállalkozás
most nem tudom hogy indult el a gondolat
de nagyon jó helyre érkeztünk mert
valójában amit mond az az hogy egy
alapvető bizalommal indultál a világ
fele hogyha te odateszed a lehető
legjobb szándékkal a a legjobb formádat
akkor az jutalmazma lesz valahol
abszolút most is volt iskolai feladat
nagyon élveztem üüm sulikba vol volt egy
ilyen azt hiszem a gimibe
volt egy olyan iskolai feladat hogy
különböző kérdéseket tettek nekem fel
interjút kellett készítsenek és akkor
volt egy olyan kérdés abban hogy mit
mit tanácsolok én azoknak a fiataloknak
akik vállalkozást akarnak indítani
nyilván én nem tudok tanácsolni semmit
én is kezdővállalkozóként ü de de azt az
egyet tudom hogy azt keresse meg az
ember magában hogy mitől tudja jobbá
tenni a világot világot vagy csak egy
embernek az életét vagy minden nap egy
embernek az életét és onnantól kezdve a
váll meg hogy mihez ért nyilván meg van
egy csomó szelete még ennek a dolognak
de szerintem ez az egy a legfontosabb
ühüm meg ebből indul a küldetésünk meg
innen jött hogy a kávé összeköt meg
tehát egy csomó minden ebből indul ki
igazából erre mindjárt rá fogok kérdezni
az oxfordot még az arra azt szerettem
volna megkérdezni hogy
a többi fiatalnak ahogy bennem is amikor
emlékszem brüsszelben amikor kimentem
egy fél évig viaskodtam azzal az
érzéssel hogy vajon elég jó vagyok-e
például elég jól beszélek-e angolul vagy
meg fogom-e tudni állni egy külföldi
környezetben magam nagyon nehezemre
esett elköltözni neked te te hogy élted
ezt meg amikor ciprusra vagy akár
roxfordba mentél én nagyon-nagyon
izgalombal mentem viszont ezt tanúsítani
tudja az az aki ott felem volt
borzasztóan honvágyam volt tehát é
egy-két hónap oxfordban végül három
hónapot töltöttem el ott egy picit
összementem ott a feletteseimmel ühüm
meg az egy az egy az egy nagyon rossz
élmény volt tehát oxford egy
szuperhely ö angliában is tehát maga az
ország az rendben volt minden jó volt
oxford egy gyönyörű hely egy olyan hely
egy olyan szállodában voltunk mintha
most kimennék mondjuk ivóba ühüm vagy
varságnak ott a a turista részeén egyen
gyönyörű szép kisebb hát nagyobb panzió
kisebb szálloda minden jó volt éreztem
egy
egy olyan dolgot mintha kihasználnának
igen ez egy ilyen ez így tehát így benne
a volt egy brit főnökünk meg egy
délafrikai főnökünküm de ő is már itt
volt tehát hogy teljesen átvette már az
ő kultúrájukat már közel 20 éve 15 éve
ott volt és egy ilyen felsőb rendőség
érzetet éreztem bennük plusz
ez még összekapcsolódott a honvágyammal
ühüm úgyhogy ott nem töltöttem el sok
időt viszont ott fogalmazódott meg
bennem az hogy én miért ne tudnék otthon
ühüm bármit is csinál mi szükségem van
nekem arra hogy kimenjek én nyilván nem
mindenkinek van ilyen rossz tapasztalata
meg sokan üümadnak meg s sokan pozitív
tapasztalatokkal jönnek haza de nekem
kellett az a negatív tapasztalat ahhoz
hogy
az hogy megkérdezzem magamtól hogy én
kell ez nekem én idejöjjek meg itt érzek
egy magasabb önbecsülést is hogy ha
valaki kihasznál téged akkor az első
gondolata lehet valakinek az hogy lehet
meg is érdemlem hogy kihasználjanak mert
ilyen a biznisvilág tehát hogy mint
csavarokat használjuk az embereket tehát
mit mit várok egyebet viszont a az az
érzés benned hogy ez ez nem helyes nem
volt fair egyébként tényleg nem volt
fair nem volt fair mert tényleg
odatettünk tehát 80 órákat dolgoztunk
egy héten egy héten igen éjszakas
lakodal minden hétvégén lakzi volt meg
mindenféle rendezvény ott mennyi ideig
voltál oxfordan három hónap az rövid idő
volt három hónap jött a két hónap után a
honvágy és egy hónap amikor körülbelül
igen és a kikértem a szabadságomat azt
már tehát márciusban ment nem februárban
mentem ki talán májusban jöttem haza de
február végén már be kellett írjuk a
szabadságunkat ez nem tudom én július
közepére volt vagy nem tudom nyár
közepére nekem be volt írva szabadságom
és ez talán május eleje volt vagy
április vége amikor egy lakzi közepén
valamin összementem egy ilyen betelt a
pohár ühüm érzés és akkor mondtam a a
kollégámnak aki szintén v eg nagyon jó
barátom osztálytásom is volt hogy gyere
segíts légyszi hogy a repülőjegyet
hozzuk előre ühüm és kérdeztem mikor
mondom most mára és akkor másnapra
tudtuk
vissza az az nap gyakorlatilag
összepakoltam cuccaimat üm és hajnalban
indult a repülő és jöttem oda és mit
mondtál itthon az embereknek vogy vagy
mi mi volt benned amikor hazajöttél
kudarcélmény volt abszolút tehát hogy
éreztem egy kudarcot meg hogy most mi
lesz velem meg jó hogy az ember
felháborodik meg a székely virtus hogy
nekem aztán most már
hazajöttem ott volt egy kicsi mélypont
igazából mert az volt hogy 2011-ben 2011
végén 12 elején talán ott elkezdtem
dolgozni annál a cégnél ahol végü kilenc
évet lehúztam ezt a három hónapot
leszámítva meg őket ott hagytam üüm nem
tudom h tehá három- négy év akkor
otthagytam akkor mondtam hogy na kész
akkor megyek én külföldre na de szép de
visszahívtak tehát az nagyon jó érzés
volt akkor mikor megtudták hogy
hazajöttem akkor visszahívtak na akkor
lett egy stabil munk meg akkor elkezdtem
édesapámnall dolgozni édesanyámnál is
beletanultam a szárazvirág kötészetbe
meg az ilyen mindenféle dekorációkat
csináltunk úgyhogy a szüleimnek nagyon
sokat köszönhetk abb az időszakb hogy
hazöttemm gyakortilag nem volt munkám
akkor anyukámnak besegítettem
szárazvirágkötészetbem apumnál sofőr
voltam és akkor utána hívtak vissza e az
előző munkahelyemre és akkor utána még
egy hat évet ott letoltam gondolom hogy
ott édesanyádall azért olyan dolgokat
tanultál meg ami ilyen esztétikai alapok
meg elrendezés meg színek meg igen de
nagyon élveztem én azt nagyon jó volt jó
volt mer most is meg tudnék csinálni egy
ilyen ik vagy nem tudom hogy hívják
azokat úgyhogy jó jó volt az nekem a
hitvallás vagy nem is t tehát úgy élek
én hogy mindennek meg kellett történnie
ahhoz hogy ebben a pillanatban mi
egymással beszélgessünk tehát ilyen
kicsit ilyen pillangó hatás szerű tehát
hogy minden minden egyes pici dolognak
meg kellett történjen ahhoz hogy én ezen
az úton így így idáig mondjuk eljussak
igen ez ez ez bennem is az elmúlt pár
évben erősödött meg lehet hogy pont a
30-as éveim kellettek ahhoz hogy ezt így
meg megértsem és sokat segített jordan
peterson hogy ezt ezt a gondolatot
megértsem hogy az az érzésem hogy soha
senki egyszer sem úsz meg semmit az
életben amit csinál tehát valahogy
mintogyha ha bármi amit ha pozitív akkor
az is valamilyen szempontból
visszaköszön az életedbe de hogyha
valamilyen szempontból megpróbálod a
másik személyt manipulálni vagy
megpróbálsz kihasználni úgy ahogy a
roxwb téged megpróbáltak kihasználni és
ez nem egy oan egyértelmű gondolat
amiatt mert amikor látjuk az oxfordi
példát meg látjuk a a politikát meg
látunk sok más hasonló példát és az az
érzetünk hogy ezt az ezt a ez az a
személy meg fogja úszni és hogy
igazságtalan a világ de valamiért én nem
ezt tapasztalom tehát azt látom hogy
hosszú távon mindig visszaköszön a annak
a személynek az életébe neked is akkor
ez a tapasztalatod abszolút abszolút meg
vannak nekem például gatyán györgyöt
szoktam követni bár oan sokat nem
szerepel üüm de ő azt mondta hogy olyan
a szerinte olyan az élet nem tudom már
idézni pontosan de hogy egy egységet
beleteszel akkor valószínűleg kettőt fog
az élet visszaadni üüm ha nem teszel
bele semmit akkor valószínűleg semmit
nem fog visszaadni ühüm meg ha csak
kiveszel belőle az se működik a én
abszolút hiszek ebbe igen
igen szóval dolgoztál kilenc évet és
lassan megformálódott akkor benned az
hogy létrehozd ezt a vekker közösséget
igen igen
a nekem már tini koromban meg
formálódott bennem az hogy valószínűleg
vállalkozó leszek ühüm
édesapám egész életében vállalkozó volt
anyukám most is hibrid módban nyomja
tehát hogy van neki egy kisebb
vállalkozása
meg dolgozik egy cégnél is úgyhogy ez
lehet hogy ha van ilyen akkor a vérünkbe
egy kicsit bennem volt meg a hugom is
vállalkozó egyébként most már és
egyszer megformálódott az az érzés
bennem hogy vendéglátásbó dolgozom de
hogy
valamit kellene szakosodni vagy
valamihez azért jobban kellene érteni
mint hogy mindenhez is egy kicsit értünk
ott a bárba meg kicsit pincérkedünk meg
kicsit lakziba dolgozunk meg kicsit
kávét főzünk de hogy egy dologhoz azért
nagyon kellene érteni kettő kettő olyan
dolog volt ami ami közül választhattam
ami úgy közelebb állt a szívemhez a
egyik a bor volt a másik a kávé és akkor
hasonuttés szerűen kezdjük a kávéval
amúgy a bor az hogy jön be a képbe hogy
t szer a bort meg magát a kultúráját meg
a mai nap pig sem mondom azt hogy értek
hozzá meg tudok különböztetni az egy
külön univerzum abszolút hát pont mint a
kávé úg pont mint a kávé pont mint a
kávé és akkor na de ez ezt akkor hogy
hát akkor veszünk egy könyvet akkor
vettem egy könyvet elolvastam kávérra de
hogy akkor gyakorlatba kellene ültetni
akkor van egy srác aki akivel mai napig
ő a beszállítónk de annak a cégnek is
ahol dolgoztam annak is ő volt a
beszállítója ő ért hozzá ért a gépekhez
meg meg tudja nagyjából a a kávéról az
alapokat akkor ő tanítgatott h na de
akkor azt még magasabb szintte kellene
emelni ez nagyon érdekes volt mert én
nem tudtam hogy mi az a specialty kv itt
itt egyáltalán nem volt
jellemző meg a szót se hallottam én soha
de kinéztem pesten egy egy
baristaképzést a madá madál
kávézó ban volt ez na és akkor menjünk
ki kifizettem a bariszta képzést
kimentem ez egy ilyen 40
órás intenzív képzés négy nap 4yszer 10
óra és kimentem és akkor az első nap
mondta teodóra
igen így hívták a lánnyt aki volt a a
kiképzőtisztünk hogy na a következő 40
órában specialty kávéról hogy miről hogy
mi az hogy specialty és akkor ott
ismerkedtem meg igazából ott láttam
kicsit mesélj róla mi az a specialty
kávé mert én nem nem tudom tehát papíron
a specialty kávén van egy az scca-nak a
speciality association az egy ilyen
globális szervezet ő mondja meg hogy a
frankót a kávétémáb ühüm ő rendezi a
barista világbajnokságot meg
mindenfél neki van egy egy egtől 100-ig
terjedő skálája ha 80 ponton fölül esik
a tehát 80 pontnál nagyobbat kap adott
kávé akkor a speciality kávénak minősül
tehát az egy préium prémium kávé
pontosan a azt kell tudni a speciality
kávéról hogy például az kézzel
szürletelik meg
a kávéról azt kell tudni hogy a kávé
cserjén nem egyformán nem mindig
egyformán érnek a kávészemek h most
hogyha ipari betakarítás van akkor
végigmennek leszedik a zöldet é a
túlérettet é a mindent a specialty
kávénál ott ott ott csak az érettet
szedik le akkor más megint kimennek
tehát hogy ilyen nagyon pepec munka is
egyébként igen tehát akkor a boltokban
amiket lehet kapni ez a csí általában
nem az általában nem azog igen az
kereskedelmi úgy hívják de ez minden
mindenfélében van csokoládéban is meg b
is meg mint és ez mennyivel drágább a a
kereskedelmi kávénál a specialty kávé
nyilván ott is függ hogy szerintem egy
olyan négyszerese de most a hasamra
csaptam de én úgy gondolom hogy hogy
minimum egy illyan három-négyszerese
minimum igen tehát most gondoltam én
hogy mennyi álunk és hogy mennyi mondjuk
egy egy fél kiló kereskedel de
körülbelül olyasmi l ott kezdődik e ott
kezdődik persze gondolom hogy itt is úgy
van 2000€ per kilós kávé is igazából ja
eg te egy rövid kitérőt mitől lesz egy
2000 eur-s kávéeh 2000 eur-s kávé fú ez
nagyon jó kérdés hát egy része ugye
tehát pont mint a bornál hogy nem tudom
milyen dőlőről származik hogy csak nem
tudom hány négyzetméteren csak ott úgy
süti a nap és akkor nyilván a a mes vag
nem mese hanem a történet is a történet
is hozzá te ittál amúgy ilyen drága
kávét nem nem nem nem ittam drága kávét
ilyet még nem azt azt meg tudom mondani
loikusként hogy a vckernek nagyon jó
kávéja van és tényleg tehát
ízre nagyon nem nem nincsenek szavaim rá
mert gondolom hogy ahoz kell t mert ez y
telesen szjektív dolog amúgy igen igen
de gondolom úgy ahogy a borkostoloknál a
someliéknél is megvan hogy most ez ilyen
ízvilága van és le van kerekítve és
gondolom hogy ennek a a szakszavai is
megvannak a a a kávévilágnak is abszol
nekem nincsenek meg de azt meg tudom
mondani hogy tényleg jó kávé ez elég is
tehát vendég vendégként ez elég is azt
meg tudnád különböztetni egyébként a
kereskedelmi kávét a specialityő
szerinted hogyha összekóstolná tehát meg
tudom különböztetni a wecker kávéját a a
bolti kávétól yes
úgyhogy akkor akkor igen ezek szerint
úgyhogy nagyon jó hát mi csak
speciality-vel dolgozunk csak arabikával
most azért a specialty világal tehát
ugye két fajta kávé van a két
legnépszerűbb az arabika és a robuszta
az olaszok nagyon szeretik hozzákeverni
az arabikához a robusztát sötétebbre és
pörkök satöbbi mi csak arabikával
dolgozunk ez egy ilyen hát azt mondják
az hogy jobbik de igazából van aki
például robuszta keverékeket hüüm is
szereti van egy ilyen kesernyésebb
karcos bíz neki
világ általábban médium vagy világos
pörkölésű és ilyen
8587 pont közötti kávékkal szoktunk
dolgozni az tehát már a kezdettől
kezdett te a kezdet kezdetén már benned
volt az hogy hogy minőségi kávéval akarz
abszolút abszolút üüm meg hogyha üzleti
szemben nézünk ez egy nagyon jó piaci
rés volt ühüm
2020-ban nem ismerté itt senki hm tehát
hogy az emberek nagy rés és hajlandóak
az emberek meg fizetni a hétköznapi
ember ezt a én úgy látom hogy igen igen
az emberek az emberek szeretik a
minőséget meg szeretik a szeretik hogyha
jól bánnak velük szeretik tehát hogy és
hogy hogy mondjam egy élm vásárol ja
pontosan pontosan de szeretik a jót igen
tehát inkább hogyha én megkérdezek
embereket akkor inkább azt mondják hogy
inkább elmegyek két naponta kávézni ühüm
akkor legyek kényelmesen gyak egy jó
kávét mint hogy minden nap igyak mondjuk
egy közepes meg hogyha egy üzleti
tárgyalásra megyek akkor nem egy nem az
a szempont hogy egy olcsó kávét abszolút
ígyunk hanem az az hogy kényelmes legyen
meg az atmoszféra jó legyen pontosan
úgyogy meg az üzleti partneredet se
mindegy hogy hol viszed igazából
pontosan pontosan még térjünk vissza egy
picit akarok majd a közösségi oldaláról
beszélni meg belemenni magába ebbe az
egész élményvilágba amit a weckerbe
tapasztaltam de ami érdekel az az hogy
miért a vckker a neve ez az egyik és a
másik pedig hogy hogy akkor hogyan is
indult ez az egész és akkor kicsit
kitérhetnék a közösségi oldalára is hát
hogy hogyan indult ugye lejárt a
baristztom képzés nekem ott már pesten
megfogalmazódott hogy na ezt valamilyen
formávan haz kell azér teljesen más
modellbe kezdtem egyébként
kerestem specialty pörkölőket azért
magyarországon
mert olyan akartam amilyen itt még
nincs és megkaptam a rostopus rostopus
csapatot szinte hónapra pontosan egy
együtt indultunk üüm tehát ők akkor
vásároltak a pörkölőket de úgy
beleszerettem az egész atmoszférába hogy
bementem a pörkölőbe tehát a földről
lehet enni mai napig tehát hogy ogogy
olyan olyan precíz emberek egyébként is
mérnökök az
alapítók és akkor abban állapodtunk meg
hogy csinálunk egy saját márkás kávét
specialty store ez volt a márkanevünk ők
rá ők lepörkölik nekünk a kávét
rátesszük a címkét azacskóra itthon én
vásárolok kávégépeket ühüm és olyan
modellben mint a kereskedelmi
nagy cégek kihelyzem a kávégépet és
akkor tőlem veszik a kávét ühüm a azok
az egységekigen két dologba ütköztem
bele egyrészt nagyon nehéz kitolni
ezeket a nagy cégeket mert ezek nagyon
be vannak
ágyazódva infrastruktúrá tehát úgy nem
nincs ah hogy versenyezni egy két helyet
kaptam oda betettem a második probléma
az volt hogy a specialty kávét is el
lehet rontani tehát hogyha nem figyelsz
oda egy csomó mindenre akkor ha nem
takarítod a gépet ha nem tartod be a
kávé a magának a folyamatnak a a
szabályait akkor azt el lehet rontani
hogyha visz nem tudod ezt kontrollálni
akkor az emberek vagy nagyon keserű vagy
nagyon savanyú vagy nagyon semmilyen
kávét fognak inni és akkor azt mondják
hogy mi ez a specialty ühüm tehát ez nem
jó de azért nem jó mert igazából jó
akkor elkezdtem
oktatni elmentem ezekrő a helyekre
próbáltam betanítani a személyzetet nem
működik ühüm tehát hogy folyamatos
kontroll nélkül ez a dolog nem működik
meg a a partnerek tehát a mit tudom a
helyeknek a tulajdonosai vagy
üzemeltetői sem figyeltteek nem az volt
az elsődleges hühüm ha jól sejtem ez
pont egy eg tehát ez egy ilyen
bizonytalan időszak volt hogy kerestél
és próbálkoztl kávéval akartam
foglalkozni nem tudtam még hogy milyen
formában p igen és akkor gondolom az idő
szorított azért tehát hogy hogy vagy még
dolgoztál párhuzamosan persze még persze
igen tehát hi biztág megvolt igen 2020
márciusában mondtam fel a munkahelyemet
üm akkor akkor szakítottuk meg a
munkaszerződésemet na de 2019-ben jött
az az ötlet hogy akkor nincs más
lehetőség a speciality akarunk
foglalkozni akkor itt kávézót kell
nyitani olin bele hát körülbelül
igen bementem a
bankba mondtam hogy az én fizetésemre mi
az a legnagyobb hitel amit üüm tudnak
adni ismertem a hölgyet a bankfióba
mondtam csillag az van hogy a legnagyobb
hiteltet amit tudsz adni azt számoljátok
ki és akkor venném is föl rá két napra
meg is kaptam ezt a hiteltet ez ilyen
miny is volt 5000 euró körüli összeg meg
volt nekem meg takarításon és akkor itt
jött ki ebbe a hugom amő kint élt
londonba tehát ez közel se volt elég ez
a pár 1zer euró persze akkor mondtam a
hogomnak hogy van egy ilyen ötletem van
ennyi pénzem még legalább kell egy ennyi
be tudnál segíteni persze nyilván egyből
igen mondott ő is és akkor ő kint élt
mint csendes társ küldte haza nekem a
pénzt meg volt nekem a pénzem kerestünk
egy helyet ugye itt a a sarkonnal ez
volt az a sark az első igen a petőfi
igen petőfi utcába és akkor ott kezdtünk
építeni egy kávézót
március talán elsején ha jól emlékszem
megszakítottuk a
munkaszerződést teljesen békében
elváltunk a az ottani kollégáimtól meg a
főnökeinttől meg tulajdtól meg
mindenkitől de ahogy mondtam hogy nekem
ez az utam úgy érzem úgyhogy kilenc év
azért hosszú idő tehát egymáshoz nőttünk
én a céghez a céghozám
és március 10-én bejelentették hogy ki
se szabad menni a házból ez 2020 már
azem 10ike de lehet 20 én 17-énre
emlékszem amikor haz költözött az egész
csapat én programozó vagyok amúgy a
hallgatóság kedvéér az egész csapat haza
költözött home officeból egyik napról a
másikra úgyhogy megint jön három kérdés
egyből covid hogyan indultatok tehát ha
nem lett volna covid akkor is egy
vízrelépés lett volna ez az egész akkor
is nehéz lett volna absolút ab tehát a
coviddal együtt ez ez megduplázódott az
is lehet új lehetőségeket hozott úgyhogy
kicsit mesélj erről hogy hogy mi volt a
tapasztalatotok te is olvasó rengeteg
könyvet meg életrajzot meg önfejleszté
meg
mindenféle általában azzal kezdik hogy
lesznek problémák vagy a vagy mindig
bele van szőve hogy készülj fel mert
lesznek problémák na én úgy voltam ezzel
hogy hát egy ezzel indítunk akkor igen
legnagyobb kihívást tehát mit tudom én
is úgy is kihívás lett volna most
kétszer olyan nagy kihívás úgy
kiszámoltad hogy mennyi ideig elegendő
az a pénz hogy hogy hát ugye azt mondják
hogy minimum hat hónapra kell len a
tartalékolni nekünk nem volt nem volt mi
amikor a az ajtót kinyitottam
2020 június 10-én amikor az ajtót
kinyitottam akkor annyi pénz volt
amennyi váltó volt a kasasszában
körülbelül meg volt egy kávégépünk amit
az a srác adott akit az előbb most
visszautalok aki most is beszállíttunk
de azelőtt is dolgoztunk együtt ő adta
azt a kávégépet úgyhogy részletbe
kifizettjük meg meghitelezett valamennyi
áruval tehát gyakorlatilag mínuszban
volt a cég nem lehet le kávézni nem
lehet kimenni az utcára akkor már
júniusban igen csak különböző
korlátozásokkal meg nem tudom
én hát kötiidegzeted lehetett akkor
abszolút de nem tehát
hogy nyilván volt veszítenivalóm de de
bizonyos szempontból nem volt
veszítenivalóm tehát tudtam hogy én amit
csinálok ahhoz értek hogyha előbb utóbb
térre esünk egyrészt vagy előbb-utóbb
beindul tehát hogy igazából meg se
fordult a fejemen soha hogy ez nem fog
ez működni üüm de másrészt pedig egye
védőhálószerű dolog volt mert tudtam
hogy én valami az értek hogyha most
véletlenül térdre esünk akkor úgyis van
mit kezdjek magammal mert mert van egy
van egy dolog amihez mindig hozzá tudok
szólni vagy mindig tudok én munkát
keresni vagy munkát kapni de de igazából
nem fordult meg a fejemben hogy az nem
fog működni tehát hogy bíztam hittem
benne meg a a könyvekben az is benne van
hogy hogy azért nem árt hogyha az ember
vakon hisz
igen meg amiben hiszel az valójában nem
egy nem egy súlytalan valami tehát
amiket megfogalmaztunk eddig hogy hittél
abban hogy a világ úgy működik hogy ha
te legjobb oldaladat adod akkor a világ
ezt ezt ezt viszonozza és kérdés az hogy
mi mi egyébben higgyünk tehát hogyha nem
ebben hiszünk akkor mi az milyen egyéb
kapaszkodónk van így a világban é
úgyhogy úgyhogy tényleg azt látom hogy
ez egy alapelv az életünkben hogy ha
értéket teremtünk ez valahol vissza fog
köszönni az élün és e pontosan így van
igen és akkor a kezdetben már vckker
kávéközöss volt a neve a a a a becker
láncnak vagy akkor még csak kvzon azt
kell tudni és akkor megint kezdem a egy
kicsit az elejéről én a a mütfön akkori
mütfön most a széken végeztem és ott az
államvizsgámot a csr-ból írtam ühüm és
mert hogy nekem az az alapelvem vagy az
a az az alapgondolatom hogy egy
vállalkozó
a a közösségéből él ühüm most ha kis
vállalkozás akkor a szűk közösségében ha
nagy vállalkozás vagy a globális akkor a
tehát így is úgy is mi abból élünk
és nekünk kötelességünk tehát ez
elcsépelt egy kicsit de kötelességünk
mindig visszaadni sőt kötelességünk
egyszer adni m az embereknek és csak
utána várhatjuk-e vállalkozóként váll ez
megint egy nagyon fontos alapelv és
egyáltalán nem egyértelmű tehát hogy én
az elmúlt pár évben kezdtem fokozatosan
rájönni erre majd egy kicsit esetleg
beszélek róla hogy miért de te miért
miért látod ezt egyértelműnek hogy kell
adni és hogy először adnod kell ahhoz
hogy kapjál és hogy ez morális
kötelessége minden szervezetnek de e így
így épül fel a világ tehát ahogy mondtam
az előbb gatyánról hogy egyszer bele
kell tenni ahhoz hogy ki tudjál venni
meg meg hogyha megnézed a a vendéglátást
és egyszer ki kell vidd azt a kávét ki
kell törtsd a vizet kényelbe kell
helyezed a vendéget és majd utána
várhatod el hogy esetleg hogyha meg volt
elégedve akkor akkor fizet meg ha nagyon
elégedett volt akkor majd hagy borra
valalód meg egy pozitív feedbet tudod
azért nem egyértelmű ez az egész
és azért is lovagolok rajta egy kicsit
mert mögötte van egy bőségmentalitás
tehát hogy jut mindenkinek elegendő ha
én elvégzem a munkámat a nap végén nekem
is elég jút és neked is elég jút úgyhaog
bőkezően adakozhatok a kapitalista világ
viszont sokszor nem ezt az elvet vallja
dzsungel harcnak gondolja a a a világot
ahol zéró összegű játéknak érzi a a a a
bizniszvilágot ami azt jelenti az
érőzágű játék hogyha te nyersz akkor én
veszítekm és mintogyha egy szelekor vagy
egy torta és szeletekre bontanánk minél
nagyobb szeletet kapsz te annál kisebbet
kapok én és ez a ami amiről te beszélsz
és amit amúgy én is nagyon-nagyon
értékelek és így így próbálja a mi
cégünk is élni az életét hogy
mindenkinek jut elég bőséges a világunk
és valójában végtelen potenciál van a
jövőben abszolút bár lehet nem úgy tűnik
de hiszünk benne gyakorlatilag ez egy
hit kérdése hogy hogyan fog állunk neki
és hogyha a vendéglátásb különösen tehát
hogyha az embereknek a vendégeknek adsz
és bőségesen adsz és itt ki fogok majd
térni a vízre külön amit az egyik helyen
a a az egyik poztba említetted hogy az
egyik különlegesség az hogy vizet is
felszolgáltok a kávé mellé ez egy apró
gesztusnak tűnik de valójában a hozadéka
hatalmas abszolút én ezt pesten láttam
először akkor mikor ezt a barist képzés
abszolút és ebben benne van a
bőségmentalitás mert nem kell külön még
megvásárolni egy egy egy vizet egy
gesztus ez ez egy gesztus egyrészt egy
gesztus másrészt lehet hogy két és fél
percet fog késni a kávé az embernek vagy
öt percet mer ug el vagyok havazva de
kitötöttem egy parvzet ühüm addig egy
kicsit kortyoggassan meg beszélgessen a
másik emberrel második poz tehát egy
csomó pozitív hozama van egy pohárvíznek
pontosan tehát hegy vicc de egy
pohárvíznek annyi hozatéka lehet és na
valahol ez a vendéglátásnak az alapja
meg meg az meg az van a vendéglátásban
hogy ha bejön az ember akkor lehet
elégedetlen lehet elégedett vagy lehet
szuper elégedett ühüm mertogy többet
kapott mint amit ő várt és valahol a
vendéglátás akkor akkor jó mikor az
ember pohárvíz már többet kapott igen és
milyen szép ez benne hogy nem az van
hogy hogy te a profitodról kellen mondj
az azzal hogy többet ha hanem e e ebben
van egy egy frappáns bölcsesség hogy
hogy valami olyasmit adsz amire amúgy is
szüksége van és nem drága nem pénzbe
kifejezhető ez egy gestztus egy emberi
gesztus abszolút meg ott a kávén a
latart meg a 80 lees vagy 70 lees csészé
tehát hogy nekem nem mindegy hogy hogy
mondjuk megveszek egy 15 les kínai
cséslet mert egyébként a vendégnek se
mindegy de lehet hogy azt nem tudja vagy
nem tudatosul benne de egyébként nem
mindegy hogy miből iszod meg a kávédat
abszolút tehát hogyha jó minőségű
kerámia csés van ami érzed hogy benne
van az anyag látod hogy kézzel megvan
munkálva sokkal jobban fog esni a káv ha
tetszik ez az epizód akkor kérlek
iratkozz fel a csatornánkra vagy írd meg
kommentbe hogy milyen más témáról
hallanál még szívesen igen ez ez a
visszatérve a közösség részhez igen hogy
méen ez a bölcségmentalitás van ez a
nyertesnyertes mentalitás hogy hogy
hiszel abban hogy csak így működhet a
világ és hiszel abban hogy ha így
nekifogsz akkor a végén én azt hiszem
hogy ez az egyik ami lesüt a a
vekkkerről és tehát ez ez nem egy
magától értetődő dolog habár neked
valamiért az volt valahonnan valahonnan
mélyről ez ez jött de ez ez de tényleg
ez ilyen belső dolok és én is ezt látom
amúgy a világban így működik a világunk
hogy először adnunk kell ahhoz hogy
kapjunk és és ez nem egy kikerülhető
alapelv úgyhogy igen a közösség részről
én is most tanulom az elmúlt pár évben a
cégünk rengeteg közösségi tevékenységgel
kezdett el foglalkozni nagyon tudatosan
és és rengeteg rengeteg mindent
igyekszünk adni minél inkább beleásom
magam ebbe a az oldalba annál jobban
rájövök ennek a bölcsességére amire te
ráírezt ebből is írtod a dolgozatodat
úgyhogy kicsit beszélj magáról a
közösségről kicsit tanuljak tőled többet
mert azt látom hogy valamiket
megértettél ez ezel kapcsolatban lehet
hogy amiket még én sem nemrég hallgattam
egy podcastet és le is írtam egyébként
moldován andrást én szeret eléggé
szeretem ha megvan a cápák között igen
igen és ő mondta egy podcastjében hogy a
legnagyobb biznis ma hogy ember számba
ved az embereket hm tehát ez egy nem
biztos hogy így van pont az idézet de ez
a lényege és ez ugyanúgy érvényes a
vendégekre ugyanúgy érvényes a
kollégákra ugyanúgy érvényes a
beszállítókra meg mindenki minden
stakeholderre aki aki részt vesz üüm
ebbe az egészbe és a hogy a közösségre
térjek ki tehát
hogy hol is kezdjem ezt az egész
történetet nekem úgy jött hogy tehát
hogyha jó fejembereket összehozol egy
tető alá mindegy hogy borozni üüm
kávézni tök mindegy mit
csinálni akkor abból biztos hogy valami
jó ki fog sülni meg hogyha tartod a
kapcsolatot meg felv a kapcsolatot meg
együttműködsz olyan szervezetekkel mint
az eszk például vagy mint a lil pont
vagy még mondhatnék másokat is akkor
abból valami jó ki fog sülni meg egy
vállalkozásnak érdeke az hogy a
közössége jó állapot jó állapotban
legyen idézőjelesen nem nem találtam
jobb kifejezést ü mert hogy mert még
üzletileg isegyébén viszont ez egy
láthatatlan befektetés tehát hogy hogy
folyamatosan tartod ezekkel a
közösségekkel a kapcsolatot ah ez ezt a
nyitottságot éreztem rajtad a
médiaműhellel kapcsolatban is hogy ha ez
egy jó kezdeményezés a médiaműhely azzal
mindenki nyerni fog a vekel is nyerni
fog a médiaműhely is nyerni fog abszolút
igen vagy
például évről évre megkeresnek a sulisok
diáknapost meg diákpolgárm nem tudom mi
lesz most diáknapok lesznek meg most
egyetem
egyetemi diáknapos csapatok is
megkerestek hogy valamivel
most adunk nekik nem tudom én
kvutalványokat
ühüm mikor a gyűléseik vannak akkor ott
tudjanak kávézni nálunk ühüm hát mi az
ha nem egy szuper közösség mikor ott
összeül 30 diák akik mit fantasztikus
gyerekek meg mit tudom én tehát
hogy ha közösséget építesz gyakorlatilag
azzal mindenféleképpen fogsz nyerni
hosszú távon igen itt úy emberként mint
vállalkozóként igen egyet értek és még
azt akartam ide hozzáfűzni hogy amikor
brüsszelbe tanultam akkor volt egy etióp
lány csoporttársam helennek hívták vagy
hívják és elmesélte hogy etiópiában
amúgy nagyon szegény körülmények között
nőtt fel hogy etiópiában maga a
kávézásnak egy olyan hagyománya van hogy
minden nap egy órát rászánnak erre vagy
lehet hogy két órát lassan készítik- el
leülnek megvond annak a ceremónikus
minden egyes lépése szinte minthogyha
egy ilyen vallási ritus lenne és leül
egy közösség és beszélget egymással és
amit még bemesélt kérdeztem hogy mi a
különbség az európai ember és a a a az
etiópok között úgy kulturálisan hogy
látja mondta nagyon hidegeknek lát
minket és kérdeztem miért gondolkozott
hogy hogyan is magyarázza el és úgy
magyarázta el nekem hogyha most egy
tegifel vonatfülkébe utazunk és két
ember megy be abba a vonatfülkébe ha egy
európai megy akkor átlósan átellenbe a
legmesszebb ül attól a személytől
etiópiáb pedig egymás mellé ülnek azért
és megkérdezik hogy hogy hívnak hogyha
nem ismerik egymást elkezdenek
beszélgetni úgyhogy ez a közösségi él
ami a kávézással jár azt hiszem hogy ez
mélyen mélyen ott van a a a tehát van
egy vágy bennünk van egy vágy bennünk
hogy hogy emberekkel időt töltsünk
kapcsolódjunk és akkor visszatérünk
megint a covidhoz amikor elindultatok
hog a covid pont hogy szétrobbantotta
ezeket a közösségeket úgyhogy ha egy
kávéközösségként indultatok egy olyan
környezetbe ahol szét aha mesterségesen
szét lettek robbantva ezek a közösségek
ezt te hogyan élted meg akkor hogy pont
az az egyik alapja ami össze kéne hozza
az embereket pont az
az hiányzik volt nekünk egy ha nem tudom
biztos sokan emlékeznek a betlen utcáb
egy ilyen egy ablakba szolgáltuk ki a
kávét igen akkor nem lehetett beülni
sehol volt egy kávégépünk oda beraktuk
kibéreltük azt a kis helyet azért hogy
mikor az emberek mennek iskolába vagy
dolgozni vagy bárhol mennek közösségbe
ahol még össze lehetett ülni akkor
vigyenek három-négy elviteles kávét hogy
tudjanak együtt kávézni tehát nekünk az
az a küldetésünk nekünk hogy az
embereknek megteremtsük azokat a
feltételeket hogy ők le tudjanak ülni
kényelmesen tudjanak beszélgetni
kapcsolódni hogyha a covid ezt nem
engedi akkor valamilyen formában
megpróbáljuk kijátszani a r idézőjelbe
kijátszani a rendszert igen és nekünk ez
vy például most kérdezték hogy hát
hogyhaog nyitva voltunk mi az ünnepek
alatt mondtam nekünk hogyha az a
küldetésünk hogy az embereknek kávét
adjunk akkor m az ünnepek alatt is ki
kell nyissunk mert akkor is akarnak
kávét az emberek igen és most ennyi év
táblatából mennyire bölcsnek tűnt ott
lehet hogy helybe gondolkoztál te is
vívottál magaddal hogy hogy helyes-e
vagy nem helyes de most ennyi év után
azt látni hogy hogy hogy tényleg ez egy
jó jó döntés volt
ha van egy tényleg egy
küldetésed és az valahol ott lebeg vagy
vagy akár ki van írva a falró akkor
nagyon-nagyon vagyis sokkal könnyebb
döntéseket hozni mert mindig ahhoz
viszonyítod pontosan mindig azt
azon tehát hogy az első kérdés hogy ez
közelebb viszi minket a ez olyan mint
egy csillag amelyik mutatja az úat p
közelebb viszi az a döntésem a
küldetésem mi a küentésetek igen az hogy
az embereknek egyrészt
össze tudjuk hozni őket tehát
megteremtsük azt azokat a feltételeket
hogy ők le tudjanak ülni és tudjanak
kávézni kapcsolódni együtt kacogni
találkozni
ühüm és ezáltal az embereknek a
mindennapjait jobbá tenni ühüm itt itt
még egy egy gondolat amire nagyon
kíváncsi vagyok hogy mi a véleményed a
én én mint informatikus főleg a covid
alatt mindenki nagyon szétrobbant és
mindenki hazament a saját kis zugába
home office-ba kezdtünk el
dolgozni és azóta se tértünk vissza az
irodába tehát hogy nem az én cégem
feltétlenül mert mi nagyon szeretünk
találkozni egymással de úgy globálisan
azt látom más cégeknél nagyon
megkedvelték hogy otthonról dolgozzanak
ennek az egyik hátránya az lett hogy
minden virtuálissá vált tehát az a marad
a a munkám is nagy nagyrész virtuális és
absztrakt de az a maradékkapcsolódási
pont ami eddig volt azáltal hogy egy
irodába dolgoztunk az
is eltűnt szinte ühüm és működik a munka
tehát hogy képesek vagyunk komplex
dolgokat megoldani de érzek egy mély
szenvedést mögötte és ez a szenvedés ez
ez ez onnan ered hogy hogy az hogyha két
ember találkozik fizikailag az teljesen
más mint hogyha skype-on beszélgetnénk
lehet ugyanzokat a az
információ információkat ki tudjuk
cserélni át tudom adni neked amire nekem
szükségem van azt meg tudom kapni tőled
de rengeteg nonverbális kommunikáció
benne van azáltal hogy valakivel leül
személyesen is beszélgetni
és pont miközben készültem erre a a
beszélgetésre fogalmaztam meg hogy
egyetlen találkozásnak annyi kreatív
potenciálja van hogyha személyesen
találkozunk versus hogyha online
találkozunk mert mi történik egy
meetingre megérkezünk öt perccel
hamarabb leülünk azt az öt percet nem
üljük csendbe hanem elkezdünk
beszélgetni viszont online térbe a másik
képernyőn elkezdjük nézni a az egyéb
feladatainkat megvárjuk ameddig mindenki
megérkezik és akkor csak a lényegről
beszélgetünk és utána mindenki megy a
dolgára viszont hogyha személyesen
találkozunk akkor megkérdezem hogy hogy
vagy hogy telt a hétvége hogy vannak a
gyerekek otthon és és amikor a meeting
lejár akkor se teleportálunk- el hanem
mindenki elmegy fizetni vagy
beszélgetünk még egy egy pár mondatot
váltunk plusz az is tapasztalató kettőnk
között abszolút ez hogy 10 perc
beszélgetés elegendő volt ahhoz hogy
öt-h kreatív ötletünk legyen am hogy
hogyan lehet a jövőben tehát egy egy
szinergiának a a az alapja lehet amikor
1eg plusz az ötté válik vagy 10zé válik
és ez az ami a közösségben láthatatlanul
ott van hogy amikor egy közösségi
alkalmat tervezünk és és belefektetünk
mert az időbe energiába és pénzbe kerül
akkor nem látható és nem monetizálható
egyből hogy mi lesz ennek a pozitív
hozadéka de ugyancsak itt a hit kérdése
hogy való ban benned is ott van ez a hit
ami most már egyre inkább bennem is hogy
az ember annyira izgalmas annyira
értékes ilyen szempontból leülnek random
emberek és hihetetlenül izgalmas dolgok
jöhetnek ki belőle egy csak azáltal hogy
hogy beszélnek és időt töltenek
egymással én ezt
a most megint mindig felhozom az erdélyi
vállalkozóiskolát mert ez nekem nagyon
nagy élmény tehát ott 17-en össze
voltunk zárva igen azt úgy értem kétszer
is elvégezted azt nem kétszer igen igen
igen az elsőt és a harmadik szélját igen
17 két ember tehát hogy nem tudom hogy
tudatosan volt-e ez kitalálva vagy vagy
valamilyen vogy volt- egy pszichológus
velük mikor ezt kitalálta ühüm de de az
hogy
összezárnak 17 embert egy szállodába
három napig vagy két és fél napig ü ühüm
az egy
olyan olyan erő összpontosulott vagy egy
olyan közösséget kovácsol hogy az mai
napig végigkíséri például az én életemet
vagy a a többiek é tartod is a
kapcsolatot velük azú abszolút abszolút
sőt barátságok meg üzleti kapcsolatok
meg meg mindenfé pusán három nap három
nap hát négyszer három nap mert ugye
négy alkalom volt és ezt ezt nekem
kétszer igen igen tehát négyszer három
nap e ez tekintélyes mennyiségű idő igen
igent és elvégzed a képzést nap közbe
este leülsz egy pohárbor egy vacsora
reggel együtt kávézó egész nap képzésem
vagy este hullafáradtam még egy pohárbor
még kicsit bele nyúlik az éjszakában üm
olyan üzletek barátságok
olyan olyan kötődés lesz hogy most
például lesz evi valószínűleg lesz evi
hogy mondják e alonni nyáron tehát hogy
az összes eddigi evi résztvevőt
mindenkit összehoznak és olyan olyan
barátságok tudnak ebből születni most
nem akarok sokszor beszéltem már erről
meg volt rádió műsor is ami dir
nyugodtan megismételheted de hogy ennek
óriási ereje van ha és visszacsatolok
most arra hogy a a fizikai találkozásnak
tehát hogyha ezt online rendezték volna
meg egy online képzés lett volna volna
akkor biztos vagyok benne hogy nem lett
volna ekkora ereje az egésznek igen igen
mert meginni az emberről egy
pohárbortest meg elfogyasztani együtt a
vacsorát meg hogy ez is hogyha
belegondolsz azért egy intí dolog
abszolút hog este elfogyaszt ez az a
bölcsesség amit én is úgy
megtapasztaltam hogy ha tegyük fel lesz
egy kliens akivel együtt fogunk dolgozni
egy évigüm akkor mindig egy személyes
találkozással kezdődjön a a a az első
interakció skype-on vagy vagy zoomon
keresztül megbeszélni az alapokat tehát
valami mélyen mélyen nagyon fontos
számunkra a bizalom szempontjából hogy
hogy a kezdeti kezdeti
egymásról feltételezett
a hitünk egymásról az úgy alakuljon ki
hogy személyesen találkozunk és utána
aztán működik az online kommunikáció de
a kezdetben nagyon fontos a személyes
találkozá h k mondod találkozzol vele
milyen a cipője hogy fog kezed szemedbe
néz közben mert online azt nem figyeled
mert h nincs is jelentőség mer lehet
pont és nem is tudsz a szemében
kama eg k k pan meg milyen a mimikája
meg érted tehát hogy olyan dolgok jönnek
át egy személyes találkozásból ami
online soha nem fog megvalósulni abszol
és akkor visszatérve a kávézóhoz tehát
hogy van egy ilyen ereje az emberi
találkozásnak szerintem soha nem fog
kihalni amúgy az az emberi találkozás
nem amúgy tudod-e hogy miért van fehér a
vágy arra hogy a az embereket abszolút
ezt ezt nagyon érdekes nem tudom hogy
tudtad-e hogy miért van fehér része az
ember szeménnek tehát a többi emlősnek
nincsen tehát az
enn az oka az az hogy meg tudjuk mondani
hogy ha néz valaki tehát hogy 10 m
távolságból is nagyon furcsa látod hogy
10 centivel arrébb néz valaki vagy tehát
nagyon-nagyon kifejlődött ez így
evolúciós szempontból a a az a tekintet
nagyon fontos számunkra és azért mert
megtud ha valakire ránézünk akkor tudjuk
hogy ő hova néz és ahova néz azt
értékesnek tartja tehát hogy vannak
ilyen kísérletek is hogy valaki felnéz
így az égre és akkor egy körülötte
mindenki felnéz az égre mert mert mert a
tekintetünkkel követjük azt amit
értékesnek tart a másik és így tudunk
megbízni a másik szemében mert ha tudjuk
hogy szám hogy hogy a szemünkbe néz ha
tudjuk azt hogy hogy a tekintetéből egy
csomó mindent kiolvashatunk
akkor akkor í akkor meg tudunk bízni
abba a másik szemébe és a bizalomra épül
amúgy egy közösség úgyhogy úgyhogy ahol
viszont nincs bizalom ott minden minden
szétesik minden minden drágább lassabban
megy az információ nem terjed úgyhogy
ezt ez az amit nem fog tudni az online
kommunikáció pótolni
még akkor sem most váttam egy olyan
kamerát amit be lehet húzni
szemmagasságba valamennyit segít de nem
de de az se fogja pótolni azt hog
érdekes szerintem nem fogja semmi soha
nem igazá nincs ez a technológia szóval
a közösségben ott van az a szinergia ott
van a bőségmentalitás ott van a kreatív
potenciálnak a végtelensége hogy bármi
megtörténhet ez ez nekem nagyon tetszik
nagyon tetszik eb a a veker hangulata
ezt ezt sugarja és még az identitáshoz
nem tudom hogy még a k közöséggel
kapcsolatban mondtál szerettél mond
valamit mert szerintem el el mondtam
vagy nem tudom de még biztos hogy még
szóba ker vissza fogunk majd persze
kerülni oda az egyik ami ami még
különösen nagyon tetszett az maga a
desájn és emlékszem amikor beszélgettünk
mesélted hogy ezt te építetted a pultot
és és a deszájnon te dolgoztál és te
izzadtad ki gyanítom hogy itt
visszacsatolhatunk édesanyádnak a a az
édesanyáddal eltöltött köz de azért meg
kell igen de azért meg kell említsük
azért például jakab huni nagyon sokat
segített az első kávézóknak am üüm ühüm
ha ő mondjuk nem úgy rakja össze akkor a
a a belső dizignt akkor én se tudtam ezt
megtervezni én erre nagyon büszke vagyok
mert én terveztem de gyakorlatilag az ő
vállára álltára igen tehát az ő keze
nyomát ühüm és a nagyon könnyű
helyzetben vagyok ebből a szempontból
mert én imádom a letisztult
minimalizmust tehát azért nincsenek a
falakon képek se igen most ha valaki
kérdezi mindig mindig mindenki
megkérdezi hogy miért nem teszünk
képeket vagy mikor teszünk már képeket a
falra azért mert ettől lesz sterilebb
ettől lesz letisztultabb tisztább tehát
hogy semmi ne legyen pluszba ühüm amúgy
nem érzem sterilnek a helyet tehát a
steril számomra egy negatív vagy lehet
hog lehet hogy más minimalistának a le
igen igen minimalista igen tehát egy
kórházhangulatot nem érzek hál istennek
viszont vis
és és azt is említetted hogy az
anyaghasználatban nagyon tudatos voltál
hogy hogy fát fogsz használni hogy hogy
hogy betont használsz meg az az ember
hogyha bejön vagy beül egy helyre lehet
hogy nem is tudatosul benne de érzi hogy
itt valami mű itt valami nem jó üüm de
hogyha gondold el
hogyha leülsz egy olyan asztalhoz ahol
egy olcsó széket tettek oda egy olcsó
anyagból
készült
asztalhoz kihoznak egy olcsó anyagból
tányérba üüm egy kaját
mit fogsz gondolni hogy milyen lesz az é
üüm tehát hogy az emberekben benne van
az hogyha érzik hogy ott minő tehát hogy
az első benyomásokból fogják tudni hogy
milyen lesz az adott termék mondjuk
hogyha most vendéglátásról beszélünk
nekem nagyon fontos például egy egy
tömör fasztal egy 4 centis tömör fasztal
ami neeket mi használunk az látszatra is
érzetre is súlyra is üüm érződik hogy az
benne van az az anyag üüm igen meg meg
meg ugyanez a helyzet a betonnal is igen
meg ugyanez a helyzet a fém is ühüm és
ugye ez a három elem van a beton a fa és
a fém plusz a zöld növények
ühüm ami soha nem lehet mű mindenki
mondta hogy miért nem cserélem le a
művirágot vagy miért nem cserélem a
művirágra mert hogy ezeket mondjuk
cseréljük fél évente jó esetben de lehet
hogy három- négy havonta mert hogy
száradnak-e mer hogy nem tudom azért azt
mondtam mert teljesen más igen milyen
érdekes hogy annak ellenére hogy vannak
nagyon realisztikus művirágok ránézel
egy vagy egy műnövény de egy dekoratív
valami ránézel és érzed hogy valami nem
s abszolút abszolút de ugyanez a
fasztalnál is így te hoztad fel a példát
a fasztal ugzt igen tehát gyakorlatilag
ez ez ezt ezt a feleségemtől tanultam
aki építész hogy hogy egy egy tér egy
családi ház egy
akármilyen helyiség egy mikrokozmosza a
világnak vagyis hogy az amit amit a
például egy családi háznál
egy jó családi ház olyan hogy megfelel
azoknak a funkcióknak am az a család él
tehát hogy hiába van nekünk egy ilyen
propagandisztikus kép a fejünkben hogy
most itt fogjuk tölteni az időnket és
ott fogjuk tölteni és így tervezzük meg
és úgy tervezzük meg hogy esztétikus
legyen ha nem praktikus akkor akkor
szétesik az egész darabjára mert
emlékszem hogy voltam egy családnál aki
aki amelyiknél volt egy egy gyönyörű
szép konyha egy nagy polttal és egy
gyönyörű szép ebédlő egy jasszallal is
úgy tervezték meg úgy álmodták meg hogy
akkor az ebédet mindig ott fogják az
ebédlőbe enni so nem ot és soha nem ott
a pulton élték az életüket gyakorlatilag
a házi feladatot ott írták a az a a az
ételt ott készítették egy egy közösségi
térré alakult ez az egész és ezt valahol
tehát egy jó építész ezt bele tudja
tervezni a úgy az anyaghasználattól
kezdve egészen az elrendezésig a
színhasználat a méretek a formák hogy
hogy az alkalmazkodjon az emberhez egy
és és ez is a másik nagyon érdekes dolog
hogy lehet életellenesen tervezni
valamit és és életpártian emlékszem hogy
hogy egy térrendezésse egy urbanisztikai
ké kérdés volt és a az egyik bank úgy
szeretett volna valamit megtervezni úgy
is tervezte meg tudatosan hogy nagyon
jól nézzen ki fényképeken viszont
élhetetlen legyen a tér a bank előtt
vagyis hogy az embereket nem akarta ott
látni nem azt akarta hogy a hétköznapi
ember ott tengenlengjen és biciklizzen
és focizzon a téren hanem hanem minden
egy picit magasabb volt vagy alacsonyabb
vagy vagy olyan zavaró volt tehát rossz
volt ott lenni fizikailag de fényképeken
jól nézett ki és van benne valami
életellenes ezzel szemben a a vckker jaj
említettem van egy identitása és és
valami vonz valami jó ott lenni és és
nem véletlen tehát ezek én nem hiszem
azt hogy ezek véletlen dolgok ahogy
mondtad is hogy az anyag hasasználata az
hogy az anyag benne legyen az hogy hogy
hogy hogy mi milyen minőséget használsz
ki de ezek pont azért tehát hogy te azt
mondod hogy nem tudod megmagyarázni hogy
miért igen de ezek pont azok a dolgok
amiket így érzed pont aok de hogyha
mondjuk
műfából lenne vagy műanyagból az asztal
meg nem tudom én most megint a csése jut
eszembe meg egy olcsó kávégépünk lenne
amelyik nem olyan kávét főz amiet kéne
mondjuk egy olcsó kávévó nem éreznéd jól
magad igen igen és lehet hogy nem tudnád
megmondani hogy miért nem érzed jó magad
pontosan de nem éreznéd jó magad
pontosan és azt is látom hogy hogy
népszerű népszerű a helyetek tehát a
amikor arra járok mindig tele van vagy
mindig vannak emberek és rendezvényeket
szerveztek amiről majd külön akarok majd
egy kicsit beszélni és és és egy
folyamatos pörgés van és és egy nagyon
jó érzésem van ezzel kapcsolatban most
ezt megemlíteném azt is is hogy 2023-ban
azért még is volt egy egy gazdasági
nehézségetek hogyha ha jól értettem a
betel ne igen a igen hát 23
ugye 22 nyarán megnyitottuk a betl 4ed
ávézónkat az volt az addigi legnagyobb
100 némes gyönyörű szép hely azt még
huni tervezte és
kivitelezte nagyon-nagyon szép
lett nem működött ühüm tehát rosszul jó
hogy volt egy csomó olyan visszajelzés
hogy a betattl 4yedben csináljunk
kávézót üm csomó hát nem volt olyan sok
nekem soknak tűnt ma mindenki uggy ette
az agyamat az nem tűt f hogy mindig
ugyanazok az emberek és nyilván azok az
emberek jártak is oda akik
ették a fejünkö hogy nyissunk ott is
rosszul mértük fel a a fogyasztói
szokásokat abszolút tehát hogyha most
szakmázni
akarnánk marketing szempontból nagyon
mellélőttünk fogyasztói szokásokat nem
jól mértük fel az emberek nem alakú
negyedekben járnak kávézni az emberek a
város központ fel járnak köpontjába
járnak igen ott dolgoznak ott suliznak
ott élnek szociális életet ott
találkoznak a többi emberre mert hogy
egyik szombatfal már lakik a másik a
betlenedbe a központban fognak
találkozni amikor hazamennek délután
3om-4-kor akkor már kávézni akkor
elmennek vagy kocsmázni vagy otthon és
milyen szép gyakorlatilag pont erről
beszélgettünk hogy egy egy kávézó is
vagy minden tér a mikrokozmosza annak a
közösségnek de valójában a ez szó
szerint így van hogy a város lüktetését
ki kell érezni pontosan pontosan
pontosan na jó és nem volt üzletileg
tartható igazából erre már rájöttünk
négy hónap után végül hat hónap után
zártunk be egyrészt nehéz döntés volt
másrészt pedig nem volt nehéz döntés itt
szóba hoznám megint a könyveket üüm meg
volt egy nagyon jó tanárom aki aki a
számok embere és azt mondta hogy ki kell
számolni ha kiadja ma te kiadjas hanem
be kell zárni ugye mindig van egy érzés
mögötte hogy ez az ilyen nem tehát hogy
ex tábla ühüm alapján azért nem biztos
hogy szívesen bezá és ezt mennyi idő
után láttad hogy négy hónap négy hónap
után láttuk hogy ez így nem lesz jobb
üüm és hat hónapután zártuk be volt az a
két hónap az nagyon-nagyon nehéz volt
emberileg is meg meg amúgy gazdaságilag
is tehát cég cég azért megérezte igen
ott azért eléggé eléggé ben viszont ha
időben nem zártad volna be annak
meglettek volna következmé ab tát az az
csőtbe is pihet vol igazából igen és
például ezzel a tanárommal találkoztam
nem tudom rá egy két-három hónap r és
azt mondja látod milyen jó vagy nem azt
mondta hogy tisztelem a döntésedet hogy
megmerted ezt hozni mert hogy
valószínűleg nem beszélgettünk azel de
tudta hogy ez nem egy könnyű döntés ü
viszont
viszont ahhoz kell igazából ahhoz
kellett a bátorság én ezt így visszamen
látom akkor nem éreztem különösenben
vagy benne voltam közepében voltam meg
nem is gondoltam ilyenekre de hogy
kellett egy bizonyos fokú bátorság hogy
akkor azt megszüntessük abszolút és
egyedül amit sajnálok hogy vannak azok a
vendégek akik egyrészt csak oda tudtak
járni kávézni mert hogy nem volt
lehetőség mondjuk központb vagy nem
tudom mi és más tehát nem igazából
igazából azokat az embereket sajnálom
akiktől elvettük azt hogy ott
kávézhatnak mer nekik pont az volt az
ideális helyszín meg éő igen és eb
éérzek egy alázatot is tehát hogy a az
arrogáns intellektus gyakran beleszeret
a saját ter teremtésébe tehát van egy
ötletünk és annyira beleszeretünk hogy
hogy nem akarjuk elengedni és több
példát fel tudok hozni magamban amikor
látom hogy hogy valaki makacsú razzkodik
az eredeti ötletéhez és ezáltal pont
csődbe viszi a vállalkozását és az hogy
te képes voltál most már többegyszerre
is váltani és és újra felállni és újra
tervezni ebbe gyakorlatilag megint
segített gondolom a vízió amit el
akartál érni tehát ott volt a csillag
amelyik vezetett téged hogy valójában ti
a közösséget akarjátok szolgálni azt
hogy hol az egy részletkérdés pontosan
tehát ja ez nagyon jól látod nagyon jól
látod lehet ezt én nem is tudtam szépen
elmondani tehát nekünk van egy
küldetésünk az hogy hogy hogy vitelez ki
vagy lesznek különböző változások meg
meg egy csomó minden közbejön közben az
az egy az egy részlet kérdés igen azt
szoktam mondani hogy én 50 évre tervezek
50 évig szeretném vezetni ezt a céget
attól szeretném hogy még tovább működjön
50 év m tehát az pont ilyen kerekszámok
2020-ban kezdtük 2070-ig én szeretném
vezetni és az hogy a második évben most
egy kicsit lett egy hullám hogy tehát
hogyha az 50 évet nézük akkor az egy
ekkora ekkora része az egésznek most egy
kicsit hullámé lesz még tehát lehet lesz
még ennél sokkal rosszabb leszünk még
fennebb biztos lesz 50 év hosszú idő
leszünk lennebb de nekem van ott 2070 s
addig addig fenn kell tartani addig ez
ez érdekes egymelege a személyiségednek
hogy egyszerre vagy makacs is és
egyszerre alázatosan tudsz váltani tehát
egyszerre vagy hajlandó 50 éven
keresztül egy víziót bármilyen
stratégiával követni de egyszerre hagyod
hogy hogy meghaljon egy egy epizód az
élet de az az epizód ha ha nem hal meg
most nem lenne a központb ká ez abszolút
így van tehát hogyha ha ha ha nem lennél
képes váltani a két extrém között hanem
hanem a akkor tényleg már valamelyik
irányba elcsúsztál volna tehát van egy
mondjuk mondjuk azt hogy van a van a cég
igen annak vannak munkapontjai
értékesítési csatornái satöbbi egy nem
működött ühüm most hogyha hagyjuk azt
nem működni akkor a többi se fog időután
működni szüntessük meg valahogy a kárt
csináljuk vissza igen
és megyünk tovább most ha azt nem zárjuk
be és milyen érdekes mert a a március
1jén zártuk be ha jól tudom február
28-as volt abb az évbe talán na mindegy
bezártuk és akkor azt mondtam hogy jó
ezt most csináljuk vissza valahogy
kecmeregjünk ki a a pénzügyi válságból a
cégnek a pénzügyi válságábó és akkor ezt
az évet arra szánom hogy csak pihenek
meg képzésekre fogok járni meg kinéztem
egy csomó képzést üü nem építünk üzletet
ami van azt megpróbáljuk jól csinálni és
két hónapra rá valaki szólt hogy üres ez
a hühüm az épület és akkor egyből le
kell csapni mert hogy az annak is van
egy története még évekkel ezelőtt a
kollégámmal akivel ity dolgoztunk a egy
a itt udvarhelyen a cégnél kilenc évet
ahol dolgoztam ott volt egy kollégám é
mindig sétáltunk els monduk hogy milyen
jó kávizzót lehetne ide csinálni nagy
ablakai vannak meg széles járda meg a
központ közepén akkor még nobilakáz igen
az volt és akkor mikor ezt így éveken
keresztül az ember ott elmegy minden nap
é ezt nézi és ezt így kívánnyas hogy
tényleg é hogy milyen jó és egyszer csak
szólnak hogy ne ki lehet bérelni ezt van
egy lehetőség hogy béred ki de egyből az
nap ühüm az nap ráborintottam tehát
gyakorlatilag már rég készültél nem nem
konkrétan erre a helyre feltétenem
konkrétan erre a helyre de de készen
kellett legyél ahhoz hogy ilyen gyors
döntést tudjá hozni úgyhogy nem volt
pénzünk mert akkor akkor zártuk be de
hát na tud hog meg tudjuk csinálni meg
nagyon sok múlik a ilyenkor a hogy hogy
hogy beszélsz az emberekkel igazából
hogy beszélsz a főbérlőve elmondtam hogy
van egy nagyon jó tervünk
a pénzt is elő tudjuk tehát hogy fele
kommunikáció volt volt amit nem tudtam
megmutatni akkor a megígértem de aztán
hál istennek igen sikerül na mindegy ez
ez egy másik történet igazából abszolút
de ez is egy érdekes kérdés
gyakorlatilag hogy a diplomácia mennyit
számít most az életünkben mert sokan
arra sokan arra gondolnak hogy főleg
mizé ek hajlamosak vagyunk nagyon
nyersen fogalmazni nagyon mert valahogy
asszociáljuk a nyers fogalmazást az
őszinteséggel de a diplomáciának megvan
a maga helye abszolút abszolút absolút
és és és a kedvesség főleg igen tehát
hogy nagyon nagyon nagyon tehát
hogy volt nekem egy pozitív
visszacsatolásom egy bizonyos tehát volt
nekünk egy stratégiánk az elején pénzünk
ugye nem igazán volt és gyakorlatilag a
második kávzot a merkurt az volt a
második kávézónk azt
a beszállítóink segítettek felépíteni
hüüm és most volt a mert azt akarták
hogy te is nyerj an an kap mer én igen
tehát hogy én azt mondtam hogy
figyeljetek rám nyitunk egy új kávézót
ez nektek is jó lesz de csak egy év
múlva egy évig egy kicsit rossz lesz
mert lehet hogy nem tudunk időben
fizetni meg hogy hosszabb fizetési
határidőket kérünk ez főleg a kávés
partnerünkre volt igaz meg a főbb
alapanyag alapanyagokat aki állította be
de gyakorlatilag ők finanszírozták é
milyen jó hogy nekem balog levente
nagyon nagy példaképem a szent király is
baloglevente őt nem ismerem még egy
magyarországi eg nagy üzletember és
anélkül volt egy pozitív visszacsatolás
hogy mi soha nem találkoztunk h de ő azt
mondta hogy ők is így csinálták annak
idején a szentkirályéval ott mikor
kezdték hogy gyakorlatilag a gyárát a
beszállító beszállítók építették föl
gyakorlatilag úgyhogy anélkül hogy én
ezt hallottam volna azelőtt volt egy
ilyen saját gondolat valószínűleg ez nem
egy ezt nem én találtam ki hanem ez egy
működő modell de hogy akkor akkor így
működött vagy így így tudtunk egy kicsit
haladni úgyhogy ezútan is hogyha valaki
hallgatja a beszállítóink közül akkor
hálás vagyok tehát ez egy ez egy szép
példa szép példa arra hogy a bizalom az
amit előreépítesz fel milyen ha ha
valaki önző és kapitalista módon akarna
gondolkozni akkor is megéri bizalmat
építeni há hogyne persze tehát nekik is
üzletileg megéri mert 95 5%a
beszállítónknak mai napig ugyanaz úgy
hogy most egyből fizetünk tehát ahogy az
áru még még olyan is van hogy ki se ért
az áru már a száml be már kifizettük
igen mert ez is egy ez is egy hála
feléjük mert hogy megígértem hogy kicsit
nehéz lesz kicsit rossz lesz de aztán
majd hüüm aztán majd hiszek benne hogy
aztán jó lesz igen egy kicsit
beszélgetnék a közösségetekről ugyanis
van maga a közösség akit szolgáltok egy
kávéközösséget hoztok létre de ott van
az a munkaközösség is a akik együtt
dolgoztok kicsit mesélj róla hogy hogy
hogyan élitek a napjaitokat hányan
vagytok ebben a pillanatban és a végén
majd ki akarok térni arra is hogy ha meg
kéne említs egy elvet az is lehet már
eddig beszélgettünk róla amit mint
vezető igyekszel élni a a közösségetekbe
akkor akkor az mi lenne
az 13-an vagyunk jelenleg velem együtt
ha jól számmolom igen 13 vagyunk egy egy
remek egy egy borz v nem szeretek ilyen
mondani hogy borzasztóan jó csapat mert
hogy rettenetesen jó csapat igen igen
nem egy egy szuper szuper jó csapat jó
fej emberekkel tehát ez az elsődleges
szempont igazából igen üüm hogy csupa jó
fejemberreel meg barátságok szövődtek
olyan emberek között akik azelőtt nem is
ismerték egymást meg fiatal fiúkból
férfiak lettek közbe ühüm akik velünk
dolgoznak íy most így megnevezzek egy
elvet vagy hy vagy hogy legyen erre egy
idézetem szerintem nincs
a próbálok úgy viselkedni velük hogy nem
hogy próbálok hanem én a kollégáiknak
tartom magamatm tehát van egy csapat van
egy cég azt azt a céget el kell vinni
üüm én is vagyok egy lánszem benne de ők
is pont ugyanolyan egyenlő lánszemek
ühüm ühüm és nem is szeretem hogyha
főnöknek szóítnak néha szoktak de csak
viccbő igen tehát nem fentről lefele
beszélsz velük hanem nem nem nem én
közöttük élek gyakorlatilag
nem azt mondom hogy teljesen demokrácia
van mert egy csomó döntést azért én
hozok meg meg a végén a felelősség is
egy csomó helyzet csomó helyzetben az
enyém üüm de de hát ezt ezt tudtam mikor
elkezdtem tehát ez igen tehát én már
mondanék egy alapelvet amit látok egyből
mégpedig az hogy a jellen fontosabb mint
a kompetencia tehát hogy ha ha ha jön
valaki akkor fontosabb hogy ez egy
megbízható becsületes személy legyen
minthogy nagyon kompetens persze hát
gondol de ez a ez ez nem egy olyan
szakma mint hogy nem építészmérnökök
vagyunk hogy itt kell egy öt éves
egyetemi tudás hogy felépítsek egy házat
hogy ne jomoljon össze de ez egy olyan
szakma amit meg lehet tanulni igen bárki
akinek van két keze két lába két szeme
az meg tudja tanni ü amúgy ezt mondhatom
a programozásra is hogy annak ellenére
hy nagyon-nagyon technikai egy
programozás hosszút távon sokkal
fontosabb
hogy hogy a jelleme a helyén legyen
mintogy egy szupersztár legyen a mi
cégünk se szupersztárokból áll össze
hétköznapi emberek teszik össze és ez a
szép ez ez a csodája a szinergiának hogy
hogy hétköznapi emberek egy csodálatos
dolgot tudnak létrehozni közösen hogyha
mindenki odateszi azt a részét amit abs
abszolút hát nézzek a a fociba mert én
focizok és abból tudok példá mindenki
sztár nem lesz jó csapat igen de hogyha
van egy nagyon-nagyon masszív közösséged
aki képes egymásé tűzbe menni üüm akkor
az legyőzi akármelyik sztárcsapatot
igazából ühüm mert van egy szív benne
van egy lélek van egy aki ehhezérrt van
aki azért van a vicces mert az is kell
aki a hangulatot csinálja és ez
spontánul alakul igen igen nem tudatosan
választod nem hát tudatosan annyira
tudatos az egészben hogy egyrészt mindig
én
én beszélgetek a leendő szerencsére már
nagyon rég nem volt ilyen de a leendő
emberrel aki jön hozzánk dolgozni azzal
egyet beszélgetek és
mi a tudatos hát az hogy legyen tehát
hogy látszik látszik valakinek a
tekintetében őszinte
nem árt hogyha nincs kilenc munkahely
előtte ühüm érted hogyha
sokszor csak átnézem például a cvket fel
szoktad hívni az előző munkahelyeiken a
a hrs-t vagy a c volt rá példa volt rá
példa mert tudtam hogy jó haverom az
akinél dolgozot ja igen és ezért
felhívtam de pozitív volt a de pozitív
volt igen igen igen igen most is ití
dolgozik a humor mennyire fontos mondtad
hogy fontos hogy legyen valaki aki a
csapatban aki humoros de a humorfelelős
hát nagyon nagyon gondold el mikor
futnak 12 órát egy nap de utána tudnak
eg jót kacagni ühüm pont nem rég vol köz
gondolom itt ott azér pont nem rég volt
az hogy kellett túlórázzan nagyon sokat
de a végén kacagtak egyáltalán most ez
van emlékszem amikor a cégünk indult én
egy introvertált személy vagyok amúgy és
az első munkatársam is egy hasonlóan
introvertált személy volt és szó szerint
leültünk a gép mellé és a nap végén
felálltunk és elmentünk és ez ez így
telt egy jó pár hónapig amikor
csatlakozott a harmadik munkatársam aki
tipikusan egy ilyen vicces bohócos
valaki amúgy egy nagyon komoly személy
is egyben tehát hogy egy nagyon érdekes
egy velege de az a humor az a játékosság
amit behozott emlékszem hogy gyúrt egy
ilyen papírgalacsént és úgy átdobta
mondta hogy pzt átküldtem egy videót
nézd meg és í közben programozás közben
n nézem hogy mit csinálnak persze utólag
fogalmaztam meg hogy hogy mennyire jól
esett az a kicsi
játékosság az a az a megpontotta a
hangulatot tehát hogy én nagyon-nagyon
hálás vagyok ezért is és megint valami
ami ami nem mérhető megint valami ami
ami amit nem lehet monetizálni hogy most
mennyit és és ennyit ér ennyit ér hogyha
valaki humoros meg kicsit lazább meg meg
meg néha egy-egy stresszes
helyzetben kincset ér hogyha egyet
tudunk kacagni emlékszem hogy kavi írta
a könyvében hogy a
pénztárgépnél valaki leejtette a tejet
na most amerikában a tejek ilyen ilyen
üvegben vannak úgyhogy egész rekesznyi
üveg tej szétrobbantott és mindenki
lefagyott és kavinak a fia azt mondta
hogy tessék kacagni
néni és és és hirtelen mindenki
elkezdett kacagni tehát az a feszültség
ami úgy hirtelen felgyűlt az úgy ki
kirobbant egy kacagásba és néha tényleg
az van hogy egy egy nehéz nap után
egyebet nem tudunk csinálni csak eteg
kacagni az mert hogyha sírnánk é
ugyanott lennénk igazából pontosan
pontosan
igen én azt látom hogy jó a hangulat sőt
egyre jobb a hangulat én is igyekszem én
magamhoz képest azt hiszem hogy teljesen
más vagyok egy kolléganőm meg is
jegyezte hogy azért sokat fejlődtem az
utóbbi időben mióta jól dolgozik üh meg
hogy sokkal türelmetlenebb voltam
mondjuk két évvel ezelőtt ü ühüm
hogy is mondjam tehát igyekszem laza
lenni üüm úgy hogy közben átadtam azt az
elvárást amit tehát a vendég legyen
elégedett ühüm a termékek legyenek tehát
a kávé legyen jól elkészítve elégedetlen
vendég nem szabad távozzon és ennyi a
keret igen igazából gyanítom hogyha
türelmetlennek tartottad magad és ebben
fejlődtél akkor most is az vagyok
igazából csomó fejlődtem és és akkor
gyanítom hogy meg is bántod a
környezetedet néha-néha néha igen akkor
or tud tudsz bocsánatot kérni abszolút
régebb nem tudtam régebb nem tudtál bb
nem tudtam most is néha úgy hogy hogy
megírom de megírom könnyebben jönnek a
szavak írva nekem igen amúgy nagyon
könnyenben is kommunikálok írva de
igen igen és rájöttem igazából nem volt
egy ilyen
egy ilyen egy ilyen bevillanásom egyszer
hogy hát basszus hát én bocsánatot is
kérhetek igazából mert hogy a bűntudat
az az bennem van még azután is hogy
bocsánatot kértem igen de az emberek
könnyebben elengedik abszolút látják
hogy nem
egyás félisten vagy azt lát hogy
azt mikor látom hogy meglobbanok
valamiért előfordul és megbántom hát
persze hogy megbántom a másik embertm
mindeszt úgy hogy ő nem akart rosszat
igazából ühüm mert hogyha látnam a rossz
szándékot akkor akkor másképp állnék én
is hozzá de ő nem ő valószínűleg jót
akart valamit elcseszett
én nem úgy reagáltam ahogy kellett volna
megbántottam akkor igen igen most már
azért bocsánatot tudok éérni és könnyebb
vagyok én is igazáb utá nagyon fontos én
is mint vezető azt látom hogy egy
bocsánatkérés abszolút a bizalmat növeli
mert tényleg az van hogy tényleg az van
hogy olyan mint hogyha egy bizalmi
bankszámla lenne köztünk tehát hogy
nagyon nehéz berakni ez a szabály nagyon
nehéz berakni és nagyon könnyű kivenni
és viszont megéri berakni megéri berakni
mert mert annyi a hozadéka egy magas
bizalmi közegnek egy közösségnek ahol
ahol félszavakból értik egymást az
emberek hogy hogy hogy hogy abszolút
megéri berakni viszont hogyha tegyük fel
valamit hibázunk akkor kiveszünk belőle
és ha viszont bocsánatot kérünk akkor
lehet hogy ez a bizalmi szint pont hogy
hogy nem csak hogy visszapótlódik hanem
még növekedik posan pont nem olyan rég
volt ez hogy a
bementem lent a merkurnál kávézóba
mosdóval közben néha problémák voltak
most már egyre több de v háromszor
négyszer és arra mentem be hogy nem
tudom csapjag a csap vagy nem tudom
bármi é most utájára mikor mikor történt
egy ilyen dolog bementem reggel f:30
vagy nem tudom már korán volt kávémot
még ki se kértem és jött a kollégé hogy
nem tudom csöpög a csap nagyon kiakadt
nagyon kikészült még a kávét se ittam
meg és ha engem nem érdekes csináljátok
amit akartok s nem tudom én s ezt a
kolléganőmnek akinek szegénynek mi köze
van hog semmi köze nem volt persze hogy
csepö csöpög a csap ő jó indulaton jött
hogy elmondja üm persze hogy
megbántottam igen na büntudatom volt de
utána elmondtam neki hogy ez nem neked
szólt nem rólad szólt a csapnak se mert
annak nincsenek érzései tök mindegy hogy
annak mit mondok ez rólad szólt abszolút
igen és ezt el tudtad így mondani a
szavakban hogy igen ezt így elmondtam
kihívtam kávézni v láttam hogy ott
kávéznak s akkor odacsapódtam hozzuk és
akkor elmondtam
ö igen vannak néha ilyenek meg ez a
türelmetlenségemből is üüm fakad na
aztán megértette vagy remélem hogy
megértette hogy én nem akartam őt
bántani igazából biztos vagyuk igen
hanem ez a szituációról szólt hogy már
tényleg már ötödik nap mikor bejövök és
valami baj van ott a mosdób és akkor
szegény jó jó mondta a az az előny a a
érzek de bolékonyság mögött van egy egy
ugye konfliktusvállaló szerep is hogy
hogy nem probléma neked egy konfliktusba
belemenni hogyha pedig én úgy érzem hogy
konfliktus kerülő vagyok igen na ezt
akartam mondani hogy én például
konfliktuskerülő vagyok és az egyik
rákfenéje a konfliktus kkerülésnek a
kétszínűség hogy hajlamos vagyok a
konfliktust lenyelni szőnyeg alá söpörni
és úgy tenni minthogyha semmi nem lenne
és emiatt emiatt én nagyon-nagyon kell
figyeljek arra hogy szembbe menjek a
konfliktussal hogy bízzanak bennem az
emberek abszolút abszolút akkor akkor a
benned is ez ez hasonló hogy
igen igen igen meg amúgy is én most
tudtam meg 36 év után hogy introvertát
vagyok én meg voltam győződve hogy hogy
extrovert extrovertát vagyok igen meg
valaki mikor azt mondta hogy introvertát
vagyok mond á nem ezt nem hiszem pláne
hogy közösséget végztem öt tesztet az
egésznél az jött ki igen amúgy amúgy
nekem is ez jött ki hogy extrovertált
vagyok de arra jöttem rá hogy azért mert
a a munkám extrovertált körülmények közé
kényszerit tehát meg kell tanuljak
beszélni mások előtt az hogy most egy
podcasten beszélgetünk amit lehet hogy
potenciálisan majd százak vagy ezrek
fognak nézni fel kell vállaljam az arcom
a hangom a véleményem tehát hogy ez ezek
de de ez nem a természetes közegem olyan
mint amikor a hal kikerül a vízből egy
ideig tud élni de utána vissza kell
kerüljön mert ha nem akkor gondolod el a
vendéglátás tehát az erről szól
emberekkel egész nap beszélj most még
tehát hogy most a
kollégáimmal de régebb kellett a
vendégekkel hogy én voltam a bárban hogy
én voltam a pinc akkor gondolom hogy nem
is introvertát emberként bocsánat
végigmondom introvertát emberként
naponta nem tudom én több 10 vagy több
100 emberrel kellett beszélgessek igen
tehát akkor valójában nem azt a a részét
élvezted a beszélgetés részét hanem azt
hogy jól tehát jól ki lettek szolgálva
azok a vendégek h is is igazából tudtad
élvezni a beszé persze persze egy
bizonyos idő után sok volt igen de
szerencsére a munkaprogram az azért
megengedte hogy néha lazicsakm sok volt
de amúgy szeret tehát hogy szerettem az
emberekkel megismerkedni
meg új vendég szerettem mikor új
vendégeket v például cipruson azt
szerettem hogy minden héten más vendégek
voltak szívesen beszélg tehát én nem is
tudom hogy lehet egy pszichológus leülni
a felekére hogyha ki kéne deríts hogy én
akkor igazából extrovertát vagyok vagy
introvertát de visszatérve erre az
introvert drogra amikor rájöttem hogy na
én akkor az vagyok meg a tesztek is ezt
bizonyították akkor így vissz mondtam
hogy ezz sok mindenn meg magyaráz igen
tehát ezt úgy lehet lehet tesztelni
magadban hogy hol pihensz meg tehát a
csendbe pihensz meg vagy pedig az
emberek között vannak olyan emberek én
amúgy nem ilyen vagyok mondom akik
közösségbe pihennek meg kihívnak
haverokat és nekik az a feltöltődés
nekem abszolút szükségem van reggel egy
egy óra csendre ahhoz hogy hogy tudjak
funkconálni rend berakjam a
gondolataimat te is így vagy nem reggel
de idlutan de valamikor amikor igen igen
meg az egyedülétet is eléggé szeretem
visszatérve a bocsánat kérésre azért is
egy fontos dolog mert valójában mindig
példát mutat egy vezető és másolják a
mintáját tehát hogy ha ha a bocsánat
kést látják hogy ez bünt nem hogy
büntetve hanem hanem pont hogy azon van
mert van olyan közeg ahol büntetve van a
bocsánat kérés a gyengeségnek a jele de
viszont ha a vekker közösségben nem ez
hanem pont az ellenkező az erőnek a jele
hogy képes vagyok annak ellenére hogy
nem kellene mert autoritás az egy
autoritér pozícióban vagy és képes len
tehát megtehetnéd hogy domináljad a
munkatársaidat rövidtávon oan is lenne
ig igen olyan is lenne pontosan ez
abszolút le fogják másolni tehát hogyha
díj azon lesz ez igen szóval visszatérve
a közösségre ami vs konkrétan a vcker
közösségére a munkaközösségre egy nagyon
érdekes dolog
foglalkoztat beszélgettünk ezelőtt a a a
a fridericus podcastről és hogy ott
nemrég ott volt ez a generációkutató
steiger vá kristián és és nagyon
megfogott az a valójában egy és látom is
a nézettségé nagyon népszerű lett és meg
is értem hogy miért mert egy olyan témát
hozott be ami azért fontos mindenkinek
hogy megértse hogy ő milyen generációhoz
tartozik és milyen a következő generáció
pontosan ez érdekelte nem is inkább az
előző a szüleim generációja érdekelt
habár az is érdekes de azáltal hogy
vezetőként évről évre haladunk előre a
cégünkkel azt jelenti hogy a következő
generáció egyre inkább részt vesz a a
munkánkb mi egy idősek vagyunk tehát az
y generációhoz tartozunk ennek megvan
maga a sajátossága amiről akár
beszélhetünk is de ennél izgalmasabb az
z generáció az a generáció amelyik tehát
húy röviden így a hallgatók kedvéért az
x y z generációk amelyik egymás után
jött az x generáció az aki az
1965-től 1980-ig született akkor jön a
mi generációnónk az y generáció a 80-tól
96-ig vagy 94-ig pontosabban és 95-től
2009-ig van a z generáció és utána jön
az alfa generáció tehát a gyermekeink
generációja már az alfa generáció és ez
az z generáció egy az egyik sajátossága
ennek hogy ez egy internetes generáció
tehát amikor ők megszülettek akkor
kezdett az internet kibont akkor együtt
nőttek fel az internettel és a
kommunikációjukon is ez ez látható
például nagyon sokat kommunikálnak írva
és kevesebbet személyesen emiatt a a
spontán személyes kommunikáció
nehezebben megy viszont nagyon-nagyon
fejlett az írott kommunikáció tehát az
ilyen hangulatjellekkel az emojikkal meg
mindenféle platformokon mindenféle
mikroüzeneteket íy ahogy küldenek nagyon
nagyon pontosan ki tudják fejezni
egy-egy karakter már mást jelenthet a
hogyha hozzátesznek és egy pár másik
tulajdonsága ennek a generációnak az az
hogy hogy nagyon figyel az egészségére a
az egészséges életmódra nem feltétlenül
amiatt hogy egészséges legyen hanem
inkább a kinézete miatt hogy hogy jól
nézzenek ki tehát hog többet sportolnak
ez nem volt jellemző a szüleink korára
tehát a a baby boomer generációra és
talán még az x-re sem annyira az y-ra mi
generációnkra már már jellemzőbb ez igen
és a másik az hogy nincsenek egyedül
tehát hog ez az összekötöttség ez ez
mindent felgyorsít mind mindent
lerövidít minden minden elérhető tehát
ez is jellemző erre a generációra de
talán az egyik ami ami nagyon érdekes és
ez a mi generációnónkra is jellemző
kevésbé lojálisak a munkahelyen tehát
hogy hajlamosabbak ha nem tetszik nekik
valami úgy ahogy elmesélted hogy hogy
angliában mi volt a tapasztalatod
hajlamosabbak
egyből váltani hogyha valami nem tetszik
igen és voltak ilyen kollégáim is és
teljesen jogosan ühüm váltottak ühüm
mert azért általában meg szoktam
kérdezni hogy hogy mi volt a kiváltók
általában el is mondják
hogy is mondtad hogy ha nem tetszik
valami igen akkor hajam tehát úgy kell
csináljuk hogy tetszedyen ühüm tehát
nyilván kompromisszum készek kell
legyünk ühüm mindenre tehát például
nekem volt olyan a munkahelyemen hogy a
telefonunkat kint kellett hagyjuk a
3310-esen volt üüm tehát aval nem
lehetett még nekem nem volt akkora híes
telefon igen nem volt akkora
hogy mondjam nem volt akkor érvágás
hogyha kingellet hagyjam a szekrénybe de
most mi lenne hogyha bemennés azt mondáá
a telefonokat hagyjátok hát elkezden
reszketni 10 perc múlva mert hogy eb
ebben nőtt föl mert hogy ott
szocializálódik ott sokszor még egymás
között is a kávézón belül is üüm írnak
egymást tehát hogy ezekhez al ezt nem
tudod megváltoztatni ühüm hanem
alkalmzkodni kell alkalazkodni kell igen
így van tehát
hogy ha nem tetszik valami akkor egyből
fog váltani ühüm arra kell törekedni
hogy mondjuk most tt úgy ahogy a
vendégeknek a megpróbáljuk megteremteni
a lehető legjobb feltételeket ahhoz hogy
kávézni meg kapcsolódni tudjanak ühüm
úgy a kollégáknak is meg kell teremtsük
a lehető legjobb feltételeket hogy ők
jól érezzék és azt hiszem hogy a bizalmi
szint tényleg ezért is fontos hogy
valójában ha egy probléma felmerül akkor
megkeresnek vele nem hagyják addig
tornyosulni a problémát amikor már a
szakadás volt erre péld és nagyon-nagyon
odajött egy kollégám és azt mondta nekem
hogy ne haragudj de ez így tovább nekem
nem megy akkor nyitottuk az új
helyet én ott szeretnék dolgoznim és
mondtam hát milyen jó hogy megkerestél
basszus hát köszönöm szépen hogy
leühettünk hogy tehát hogy megtisztelő
is volt hogy nem azt mondta hogy na én
akkor felmondok nekem gondolom nem
örventél neki azért dehogy nem tehát
annak is örventem egyébként is az volt a
tervem de ő azt nem tudta de az volt a
tervem amit ő eleve akart hogy hogy
segítesz neki átmenni a másik kávzóba
igen igen és mi miért volt ez a terved
azért mert ő egy nagyon jó szakember is
meg nagyon jó ember is meg nagyon nagy
tapasztalata is van most már és úgy
érezted hogy nem tudod azt a benne levő
potenciált megfelelően lekötni nem úgy
éreztem hogy kell egy egy magas
tapasztalattal és jó tudással rendelkező
ember ahhoz hogy egy új helyet el
tudjunk indítani nekem ez volt az
indítatásom ő ezt nem tudta én se tudtam
azt hogy neki ilyen ambíciói vannak hogy
az új kvézóbaan akar dolgozni
ez így pont véletlenül jött össze de de
nem is ez a történetben a lényeg hanem
felhívott külön ühüm hogy szeretnék
beszélni veled ühüm de telefonban nem
tudom elmondani személyesen üljünk le
ühüm mer beszéljük meg leütünk é egy
férfiember ült előttem tehát egy
felelősséget vállaló férfi üt előttem
ühüm aki amúgy két évvel azelőtt egy
köök volt aki akkor szabadult vagyis
akkor jött ki a sulibba és
elmondta hogy szemembbe mondta leült s a
szemembe mondta hogy mi a problémája és
ezen tudunk változtatni hogy egy kicsit
az ördög y végje legyek tehát annak
annak hogy tudtál örvendeni hogy a
konkurenciához egy jó szakember fog
menni nem nem nem nem nem a mi másik
kávézó jó jó jó jó j j azt hittem hogy a
konkurencia értem értem értem nem nem
nem nem nem akkor rosszul fejeztem ki m
én értettem félre jó tehát a régi vagyis
a a merkur kávézóbó a kolléga nyitottuk
ezt az új helyetz
od szeretett nem nem rossz fél é tetted
akkor vagy én mondtam rosszul jó jó így
így már más a történet de a az is egy
érdekes dolog lett volna ha annak
örventél volna hogy a konkurenciához
megy de hát annak már nem tudom vagyis
hogy volt már ilyen is
hogy mondjam nem örültem de nem azért
nem örültem mert a konkurenciához megy
mert ott onnantól kezdve hogy elmegy
tőlünk azt csinál amit akar igazából
hanem az hogy elment meg azért kudarc
nekem is nyilván igen igen hogyha valaki
és volt erre példa hogy felmondultt
valaki igen és a konkurenciához ment
persze persze persze volt ilyen üüm volt
ilyen de it mondom a kisebbik baj az
hogy a konkurenciáz megy ühüm nagyobbik
baj az hogy hogy elment mit csináltunk
rosszul igen mert mert hogy kettőál
mindigó tényleg nagyon szép hogy így
látod mert mert benne van ebben is az a
az amit mintaszerűen felismerek ez a
bőségmentalitás ami ami körbevesz téged
hogy az ember fontosabb mint a mint az
aktuális profit az aktuális profit kell
nem nem arról van szó tehát ki kell
számolni azt a kölség ló tudod tehát
hogyha nincs az emberek nem érzik jól
magukat akkor nem lesz abból ühüm vendég
se meg nem lesz abbó pénz se meg nem
tudunk építkezni se kicsit fordítva kell
gondolkodni egyszer az ember érezze jól
magátm és akkor abból lesz igen még egy
egy kérdés húgy felmerült bennem így le
is írtam nem tudom hogy erről akarunk-e
beszélgetni különösebben mert most már
kezdett kiérződni a válasz is erre
mégpedig az hogy a wecker és egy
starbucks között ami két véglet bizonyos
szempontból mi a hogy tud felnövekedni
egy kávézólánc akkorára mint a starbucks
és neme veszíti el azáltal hogy egy
starbucksel növekedik azt a azt a
személyes kapcsolatot vagy igazából a
starbucks egy pozitív példa mert talán
az egyik legnagyobb tehát hatalmasak és
a másik oldalról pedig csak jókat
hallottam a közösségükről a belső
kultúrájukról hogy ez ez az egyik kérdés
és ak esetleg reagálhatnál arra is utána
hogy nem meg gondolkodtál arra hogy egy
starbucksot ideehozni székelyudvarhelyre
vagy akár egy frej kávézót vagy valami
franchiseba bekapcsolódni az már nem
lett nem olyan lett volna ühüm a
starbucksot amúgy nem is lehetne talán
mert nincs akkora lakos unk mert azot
talán ehz meg talán frej se nem tudom
nem gondolkodtam ilyenben igen meg hogy
mi adja a varázsát a starbucksnak hogy
hogy azáltal tehát hogy hogy hogy látod
hogy hogy milyen utat kell bejárjatok
egyáltalán akarsz-e bejárni egy olyan
utat ahol egy olyan kávézóláncot hozol
létre ami több országon keresztül íveel
vagy több városon keresztül íveel nincs
öt éves tervbe igen de ezt meg szokták
még kérdezni és ugyan ezt szoktam
mondani tehát hogy nincs így se a
fejembe se leírva a
rövid középtávon biztos n ezt akarjuk
jól csinálni ühüm amit csinálunk most
hogy én olvastam schulcnak a könyvét a
starbucks alapítónak kétszer is
üüm nem tudom hogy hogy mit csinál de de
a ott is a amit mondtál az előbb hogy
hogy van egy érzésed amikor bemegy tehát
hogy ők brandingbe meg belső dizájnba
meg egy csomó mindenbe fantasztikusan jó
üüm nem véletlenül van 300 vagy nem
tudom mennyi sok 10000 ühüm boltjuk igen
a globális szinten meg van egy üzleti
modell azért igazából ami ki van találva
tehát hogy schulz mikor
a megvette a starbucksot akkor egy
boltjuk volt lehett kettős onnan 50 k hm
tehát ő körbekad nem tudom hogyha nem
olvastad azt a könyvet azt érdemes
elolvasni nem de kicsit foglalkoztam a
témával magát a könyvet nem de az azt
azt fickó valami 250 befektető
utasította vissza hm érted tehát azt a
azér képzeld el azt a azt a kitartást
meg azt a 250-en vissz a 251hez is
odament annak is letette a koncepcióját
hogy ő egy nem tudom már hogy 25 vagy 50
de ilyen nagyon nagyon nagy léptéket
ilyen 10-20szoros léptéket lépett egybő
ühüm mert hogy ő azt mondta hogy ez
működik adjunk el espresszót gőzőtejjel
akkor még ez volt a modás a
koncepció hogy ez azt mondta hogy ez
jóüm ez jó lesz bízuk és egy olyan
helyen ahol a kávékultúra nem volt még
elterjed pontosan hát az ilyen izét
ittak ilyen filteres igen lö ittak amúgy
most már filterkávénak is y nagyon jó
kultúrája van meg meg fantasztikus
dolgokat ki lehet hozni filteres
módszerekből de nem kell mondjuk hogy
amerikában mondjuk a 60-as
70-esekben milyen kávén éltek az emberek
és ő azt mondta hogy hát adjunk
eszpresszót gőzől tejjel és higgyétek el
hogy ez gondol 250 emberhez odament
milyen mit tudom ilyen nagy befektetői
házaknak a vezető nem tudom ki kiktől
kérte a pénzt é higgyétek el hogy jó
lesz és ő hit benne 250-en nem és aztán
volt neki is egy csillaga ami vezette
abszolút abszolút az egy nagyon-nagyon
jó könyv vonot el lehet vonatkoztatni a
kávétól mer igazából nem is arról szó
hanem arról
a arról a mentalitásról meg arról a
világlátásról ahogy ő látta az egész
világot üüm és ahogy eljutott idáig
egyébként ők is megtérdeltek talán a
90-es években nem tudom hogy az elején a
végén márg nincs meg tehát voltak nek
isis hullámaik igen képzeld el hogy most
elmesé azt a sztorit úgy volt hogy nem
tudom én 10 év után vagy sok év után
először ment el nyaronni a családjával
üüm két hétre és egy hét után hívták
hogy bedőlt a a kávépiac nem tudom
két-háromszorosára nőtt a ühüm valahogy
így volt a sztori már nem nem tudom
pontosan hogy hogy volt de hogy
megtérdelt a kávé piac akkor már
nagyon-nagyon sok boltjuk volt tehát azt
jelenti hogyha mondjuk 20%-ot emelkedik
a kávinak a világpiaci ára akkor az az
érinti abszolút őket és akkor azt mondta
hogy hét múlva feleségének hogy ne
haragudj de én haza kell menjek ühüm és
akkor ők szinte megtérdeltek de ahogy
azt is leírja hogy hogy vészelték át meg
meg leültek s döntést kellett hozni meg
meg hogy raj a igen az is benne van hogy
jó hogy volt neki egy nagyon jó csapata
akkor már igen de az egész felelősség az
övé volt teát a végső döntés így is úgy
is az övé volt és nem tudom én több száz
vagy több 1zer boltról beszélünk akkor
már és tősd egy cégről akkor na jó az a
jó az a könyv az azt ajánlom esetleg ha
eszedbe jut a címe most így a h schulz
a nem jut eszembe szerintem aki akarja
meg megtalálja it is ez alapján
lassan a végére érkezünk a még a
beszélgetésünknek még van két rövid
kérdésem az egyik az hogy nehezen tudom
eldönteni hogy most egészséges a kávé
vagy nem egészséges a kávé ha rákeresnék
mind a kettőre kapnék cikkeket te most
hogy látod ennyi kutatás után
én a jó választ akkor találtam meg mikor
írtam az államvizsgámat
üüm mert beleírtam hogy
a hogy számtalan kutatás bizonyítja azt
hogy a a csr-rólírtam az államvizsgámat
de azon belül is voltak kávés témák
benne hogy számtalan kutatás bizonyítja
azt hogy a kvénak egészséges hatásai
vannak és akkor a a vezetőtanáromnak ezt
elküldtem s ő aláhúzta kétszer pirosal
és odaírta mi vagy te orvos tehát hogy
én azt nem tudom megmondani egyrésze az
embereknek ezt mondja másik része azt
mondja szerintem vannak pozitív
hatásai a szervezetedre meg vannak
negatívok is nyilván
mint minden másban mérték szerintem a
fontos ühüm az azért elég nagy
konszenzus van a ebben mert azt mást nem
nagyon ol tehát én három- négy
eszpresszónal nem ajánlok többet ühüm
naponta egy felnőtt egészséges
embernek ha a mértéket betartjuk
szerintem nem lehet baj nem lehet ha
most vissza v meehetnél az időbe tegyük
fel od amikor oxfordból
hazatértélm mit csinálnál az attól
kezdve másképpen mondtad azt is hogy
semmit mert bizonyos
szempontból annak a produktuma vagy amit
megtapasztaltál de mégis esetleg hogyha
kiemelné két-három dolgot amit ha nem is
csinálná másképpen mégis úgy azt látod
hogy ezek a dolgok amik talán
elkerülhetőek lettek volna van-e de
hogyha elkerülemm akkor nem lennék itt
úgyhogy nem nem nem nem nem tehát
nyilván van egy csomó rossz döntésem
vagy volt akkor is most is van és lesz
is még de minden kell ahhoz hogy hogy
eljussunk igen vagy hogy vagy hogy
leéljük ezt az életet úgy ahogy
szeretnénk még egy utolsó kérdés még
bele fog férni
egy fiatalnak aki most 18 éves mit
tanácsolnál
hogy mit kezdjen az életével elvégez
tegyük f
leérettségizet költözzön el utazzon el
aljon vagy esetleg jöjjön vissza vagy
vagy tanuljon
tovább
ha el is mondom hogy mi a mélyebb
kérdésem ezzel kapcsolatban a
fiatalok teljesen más kontextusban élnek
mint amikor mi voltunk fiatalok a világ
felgyorsult és egyszerre látunk egy
csomó ideált magunk előtt ami szinte
elérhetetlen magasságokban van gazdag
fiatalokat akik akik influencerkednek a
legtöbb fiatal influencer akar lenni
és és másik oldalról pedig benne van a
félelem a fiatalokban hogy mi mi
egyáltalán elegeke ennek a világnak és
ez az ai forradalom nem segít ezen tehát
hogy annyira fog változni a a piac és
annyira fog változni a a a a
lehetőségeknek a halmaza amivel majd
szembe kell nézzen hogy mire elvégez egy
egyetemet lehet hogy az a szakma már nem
fog abban a formában létezni tele
vagyunk bizonytalansággal egy
felgyorsult világban ahol tele vagyunk
ideálokkal amiket megpróbálunk követni
de nem tudunk felnőni hozzá szóval itt
van ez a fiatal aki aki bizonytalan és
gondolkozik hogy egyáltalán érdemes-e
bárminek is nekivágni mit tanácsolá neki
ugye nem nagyon szeretek tanácsokat
osztogatni mert még én én se tudom
sokszor hogy mit tegyek de igazából az
első dolog az hogy és ezt
hogyha mindegy az első dolog az hogy
mindig saját magához mérje magát m tehát
ígyíy mondtad hogy influencerek meg nem
tudom meg a világ tehát az nem igaz amit
a tiktokon látsz meg az instagramon de
ezt mindenki elmondja egyébként ez már
elég még már lassan közhely tehát hogy
az az nem a való világ amit a tiktokon
meg a az instagramon látsz úgyhogy
mindig magadhoz próbáld igen hasonlítani
magad vagy
viszonyítani magadat és a másik dolog az
már az elején a legelején is
amit mondtam hogy azt gondolom hogy
találja meg hogy ő milyen formáb tud
szolgálni milyen formában tudja
szolgálni a világot üüm és hogyha ez
megvan akkor akkor gyakorlatilag az
élete egyenes h de az legyen tehát hogy
vannak különböző dolgok ha te abban vagy
jó hogy az embereket egészségesebbé
tegyed akkor ha abban vagy jó hogy a az
embereknek asztalokat gyártsá mert hogy
ez egy funkcionális eszköz amire mindig
biz mindig biztos szükség lesz ha te
abban vagy jó hogy hogy szolgáljad őket
mint vendéglátós meg hogy jó ételeket
főzzél neki vagy egy jó kávét akkor azt
csináljad tehát hogy meg kell keresni
hogy hogy tudod szolgálni az embereket
igazából ennyi a titok azt hiszem ez
tökéletes lesz
végszónak köszönöm szépen ezt a másfél
órát talán ami ami így elrepült és
igazából félnek tűnt nagyon gyorsan
elrepült igazából a kérdéseim felé
tudtam csak feltenni de ez így nagyon jó
volt ez így nagyon jó volt és mindenkit
bátorítok ha székelyudvarhelyre jösztök
akkor mindenképpen a vekker kávézóba
térjetek be ha pár évet vártok szerintem
nem csak székely udvarhelyre kell vagyis
hogy lesz lehetőség etek betérni egy
tényleg egy különleges hely és amikről
beszélgettünk ma ezekről az alapelvekről
igazából ezek nem egy kávézónak az
alapelvei ez ez ez minden egyes
szervezetnek az alapelvei kellenek
legyenek tehát hogy az hogy most kávéról
beszélgettünk én azt hiszem az a te
elhívásodról szólt de azokat amiket a
bölcsességeket amiket megfogalmaztál
azokat a mi cégünk is ugyanúgy kell élje
ugyanúgy kell élje egy építkezési cég és
ugyanúgy kell egy fogászat éje úgyhogy
én nagyon hálás vagyok hogy ennyi
mindent ki tudtunk hámozni köszönö
szépen köszönöm szépen hogy itt voltál
szép napot neked neked is nektek is ha
tetszett ez a műsor akkor iratkozz fel
kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel tudsz
támogatni minket köszönjük a vckker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az ötvös
udvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre